there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on
it's wednesday here we are once again
doing the [ __ ]
you're sleeping you saw you're sleeping
jenny no i said well you know hey i've
had a long day yeah you know i've been
and i had a long day yesterday i
actually have a long day every day all
right i'm always like working today's
show
are the unexplained mysteries of john
wilkes booth did the the mysteries the
unknown mysteries shit's mysterious it's
really not mysterious
it's like shut up it is too good it's
mysterious
i'm watching pookie pookies down there
throwing throwing your own toys how
pookie that's right catch them
she's throwing them well tom was trying
to throw the toys but she was like no
she's like nope not throwing in this in
this room she wants to throw her own
that's right in the living room she
wants me to throw over and here she
throws him herself she's throwing it
down look she's got the [ __ ] mouse
she's funny yeah
every little place every little place in
the house has its own purpose and
activity
she'll only do certain things in certain
houses certain part of the house yeah
it's weird she's she's well everything
is a pookie station she's set in her
waist yeah yeah she has pokey stations
all over the place
but yeah so you know i feel like we
haven't done like maybe a american
history one in a while
i actually did get the idea to do a show
about john wilkes booth
from
like i think it was what was it at the
the chat show the chat show that's what
i call it it's a show
that's why i call it yeah it's a chat
show i'm sure somebody had to on the
crew of that show like how to make the
jokes he doesn't like to be called that
every day i know but come on he's like
what are you going to do about it old
man well no i'm just saying it's like
but i mean for the purposes of that joke
you would think that he would make an
exception but you know i'm just saying
that uh i just call it the shadow but
because it's just called the unexplained
which is it's too generic he's awesome
in it he is he is awesome he hams it up
through the whole [ __ ] thing he
doesn't break character
we don't know what happens you know like
what can save us from the devil
[Laughter]
if the devil exists how can we protect
ourselves from him
yeah it's very much like that yeah yeah
and i'm just like that's right ladies
and gentlemen yeah that's right
let's find out let's find out yeah
it's a good show though yeah yeah i mean
but some of this stuff i think it's
funny like how they have they do like
all the devil [ __ ] and then they have to
like keep a straight face like yeah yeah
yeah yeah but uh yeah but but i think it
was either on that show or some other
kind of like history channel show that i
saw and i was like oh yeah that's right
there was like a weird theory going
around like back in the day
that
uh john wilkes booth didn't actually get
killed
when they say he got killed and that it
was like a look-alike
and that he actually lived in his old
age because it wasn't there something
like some guy like on his death bed and
he was like oh i'm really john luck's
booth and all the other kind of stuff
yeah if some some people thought that
the the guy that they did kill wasn't
john wick's booth it was another guy
yeah there's all kinds of stuff that
that booth actually got away
some people think he went to japan yeah
there was that story
the assassination
was actually an advanced
confederate special operation it was
like a vengeance mission
the question was is
how organized was it and did the
confederate government have a
did the ex-confederate government have a
hand in it
i mean i kind of feel like at least from
what i read they're like well there are
that's it's possible
um unlikely though but probably not but
we're going to get into that yeah that's
what the show is about like not
impossible but not likely
not likely
because well that's why i kind of felt
like
so what you know when i was like oh
maybe we could do a show about that but
then like when i started researching
just the guy i'm like well actually just
his story on its own is like actually
interesting enough a lot of [ __ ] i want
to say about it right now but i'm have
to hold it back
to save it because you're getting
moments on this [ __ ] oh really
oh this should be good you know if
you're new to the show jenny and i are
both
southerners
i've traveled everywhere though but my
family's [ __ ] from mississippi
[ __ ] heidelberg mississippi right
above laurel
about 90 something miles maybe 70 miles
from [ __ ] tupelo it's like a deep
south all right i know the culture very
very well so does she she's more like
northern part of florida kind of
she's from daytona or deltona daytona
but the culture is very similar to what
you'd find in the panhandle or in the
other places in the south florida is the
south
but it's kind of like tropical too it's
also partially
it's partially uh
like the caribbean mixed in with it too
but so was so was
so is louisiana
it's
got a lot of haiti and france mixed in
with it in spain
you know
this was all spanish territory at one
point and it in french territory in
other places and then
british and
then it became part of the union and
then the union broke up
and it became you know the the
confederation and that was around for
only a few years and it got [ __ ]
crushed out
and then long campaigns are basically
kind of like ethnic cleansing to a
certain extent just not quite directly
there were concentration camps here
a lot of guys died in them they tried to
kind of [ __ ] cover that up and
reconstruction didn't go well and the
south descended into a basically a race
war
that went on for a long time
and uh
racial segregation was kind of like
south africa in certain places you know
and just
the south has a troubled history but
it's very colorful and far more
that's one way of putting it yeah it's
very colorful
mississippi is like the north korea of
america buildings monuments to long gone
heroes or heroes that never existed and
everything was just a big middle finger
to the north
it was mostly just a [ __ ]
it was a fight between white people that
went all the way back into the honky
motherland because the
ethnic makeup of the white people in the
north and the south was different even
way back in the 17th and 1800s and the
1900s it just
and
we'll get into it as it goes on but you
know there's a lot of good programs on
it if you're more interested in it it
was a lot more than just politics or
slavery it predated all that
it was
it was a fight over money and
how english you were weren't
had a lot to do with it
you know what i mean how irish you were
weren't or how german you were worked
you know it was a factor and
the northerners were more
scandinavian and british kind of than we
were
the south was more
irish scottish german and french
with spanish
so
and the united states was always just a
damn
patchwork quilt of a bunch of damn
warring ethnic groups
the union was designed to keep them from
directly fighting
and they'd had a central representation
in washington dc and
everybody always tried to game the
system
to send the money in their direction
it's just been a long that that's part
of what
happened during all that
and new people kept coming in which kind
of diluted diluted it and
um
things were forgotten and
but the south certain parts of the south
never forgot any of this [ __ ]
my grandparents hated northerners hated
them
as if they were from another country
and that they didn't deserve to
exist that's that's what it was like man
now my grandfather was like that yeah my
paternal grandfather yeah my mom's side
of the family are actually from yeah
maryland where what john wilkes booth is
for me in those days if you were a
northerner and you were in mississippi
or what you were putting your life at
risk
if you were a federal agent in
mississippi you were putting your life
at risk
you know
the
the
the cops here would get you
you know
they were [ __ ] it was just
it was wild man
ben frail says the knights of the golden
circle wanted to establish a slave
empire centered around cuba yeah and
there actually were rumors i don't know
if they're true or not uh that john
wilkes booth was a member of that i'm
not entirely sure if that's ever been
established but that is one rumor that
comes up every now and then yeah because
he was a big fan of slavery big fan yeah
big fan yeah now
um
hollywood and
modern cultural will
kind of lead you to believe that
slavery was
popular in the south and that everybody
agreed on it
mississippi
had most of the slaves
per capita it you know it had most of it
was right there in mississippi
but even there slavery was banned in
half the counties
so you had free counties and slave
counties and they were constantly
fighting with each other
and is because slavery is not a good
economic
model
it sucks all the money out of a [ __ ]
economy
it just impoverishes everybody and then
it enslaves innocent people
so you know even in mississippi they
were trying to stamp it out
it wasn't going to go anywhere though
because
fighting
plantations owners was kind of like
fighting drug cartels or mobsters they
were very powerful very ruthless and
they would kill you literally
if you can't win up against them
and if you were a poor white person
trying to do some become a farmer and
make anything for yourselves you'd never
be able to sell that stuff at prices
you could never compete against stuff
that was coming out of plantations so
all the money was just sucked away
so you know
it wasn't popular like people think
um
and really during the civil war
they kind of had to
see there's a real good movie called the
free state of jones my family's from
jones county
and the jones county
fought against the union and the
confederacy eventually it was like a
rebellion
that
had
whites and blacks fighting against the
confederacy
um because you just
they
why would poor
white people who could barely make it at
a farm why were they being forced to
defend a bunch of plantations
that's really what it was about
plantation owners had to basically trick
them to do it and turn it into a thing
of honor like they've invaded your
country you have we have to get them out
of here
and what would they have to look forward
to just being poor again in that damn
shot gun shack [ __ ]
growing crops that really you couldn't
sell in the market you only had to eat
them because if you sold them in the
market really you wouldn't get anything
for them because that's what everybody
else did
you know you couldn't you couldn't
you'd have to you had to match the
prices that of what the what the uh
uh
the plantations were selling and you
couldn't match those prizes well
obviously because they weren't paying
their workforce no
yeah
plantation was
like you know they their their their
their [ __ ] operating costs were low
and um the and the thing is is that you
know i'll talk would talk about food and
cotton
cotton probably was like one of the
biggest exports
into the other states
probably where most of the money came
from but that's really only the tip of
the iceberg when you when you those
plantations also made furniture
clothes
clocks
real high value items
and
you you just couldn't compete with the
[ __ ]
prices you know and when you when you
think of a of a slave worker you think
of a person picking cotton no they had
some of them [ __ ] highly skilled
craftsmen that could make a clock a
[ __ ]
yeah that's a high tech that would be
like you making a damn laptop computer
right in those days
they could make guns
in plantations you know they did all
kinds of stuff it's just that it wasn't
it was kind of like a cottage
there wasn't any any mass
production uh in terms of like uh you
know they didn't have big factories it
wasn't but the industrial revolution
hadn't really
taken root in the south
at this time
so you so they could make things but
they couldn't mass produce them
so when the south kind of got in a
situation where
it had to equip its own troops and they
lost the support of france there's no
way
to get together and say make a
standardized rifle or a standardized
cannon that required too much
organization and the supply lines that
the south
didn't have and
they just weren't going to be able to
produce their way out of that war and
the limitations of southern culture they
were not going to be able to fight a
kind of war that they would win because
the southern
southern society and its culture was
equipped real similar to say
medieval japan or feudal japan it was
like that
a daimyo was kind of like a plantation
owner
it wasn't it was an aggregate society it
wasn't industrialized
um
it was very individualistic it was kind
of class based you know what i mean
um the samurai
was kind of like the plantation class
where
the samurai had the power of life and
death over japanese merchants and and
worker classes they were kind of like
the law enforcement officials they could
really and you think with samurai you
think of doing it on battlefield but
most of the samurai were just the guys
that wrote books and [ __ ] and carried a
damn sword
but if you thought you committed a crime
or did some broken rule he'd kill you he
had it was his authority to do so
the south was kind of like that
um
it was more
honor based than legal based
so when the war broke out
they had to fight what they would
consider to be an honorable war and then
they were saying this so they it would
have to be a conventional war which is a
european-style war of [ __ ] lighting
up in big [ __ ]
skirmish lines are shooting at each
other with cannon and [ __ ] the suicide
really
south could have never won a war like
that against the north it would have had
to have been
a guerrilla war which some of that did
happen but not enough it should have
been primarily a guerrilla war if the
south wanted to win they should have
just left the army the invading army
right in with no resistance and then
once they were in terror campaigns and
you'd eventually drive them out same
thing afghanistan and iraq did to us
that's how we should have won it but the
south wasn't didn't think that way it
tried to put its best foot forward and
was trying to say no we're civilized
just like the north so we're not going
to play that game
now jones county did just watch the
movie it's called the free state of
jones
this is the terror campaign
uh can you hand me that uh that little
uh
paper thing over there that little thing
yeah because um ben frail said this was
actually a great idea he said you should
do a true crime video on the sally
miller's salome mueller slavery case
which was in the book the lost german
slave girl if you read it i have read it
uh i read it a couple years ago and it's
really really good and i agree that that
would be and i would never have thought
to do a show about that but i'm gonna
write that down because yeah that was an
excellent book and it was really really
interesting
so thank you for that i will put that in
the next patreon poll and we'll see how
that goes
so the south basically kind of got
each southern state fought the union for
different reasons
it started off as a a peaceful divorce
between the states
the north did sign a peace treaty with
the confederacy that was kind of like a
non-aggression pact
but
some of the
in one of the places uh a military
post was inside southern territory and
they captured it and then the south went
in there and invaded to take it back and
this and this fighting started and then
the war got declared so the the peace
treaty didn't last long
the south interpreted that as the north
breaking the
the peace treaty
and uh therefore they have uh in broke
the peace treaty the deaths are the
scoundrels blah blah they've invaded the
country they whipped up the southern
population to fight an invading force
that they didn't get along with for even
for years before this
each state
fought the the union for its own reasons
and
some of the [ __ ] [ __ ] went back
decades and the first one to actually
leave and i think the first one to
actually secede i believe was florida
and florida was just a mixed state it
was more like something from the
caribbean than it was uh and it was
heavily hispanic
uh it was more like something from the
spanish empire more than it was from the
united states
it was just uh
chaos really the south was chaos the
civil war was chaos
more than anything else big time well
and like i was going to say when you
know when you talk about each of the
states like having their own thing like
things are a lot more complex yeah john
wilkes booth in particular was from
maryland which was
a slaveholding state
but they chose to stay with the union
and did not join the confederacy yeah
that's another thing so it's called the
border state they did have those as well
yeah that's another thing
the the war didn't really have anything
to do with slavery
it wasn't until after the [ __ ] war
that war had started the north brought
the slavery issue to the front saying
we're gonna finally get we're gonna
finally free those slaves and stop
slavery
it's true that the north had wanted to
end it
they had been telling the south look man
that's unconstitutional you can't do it
and a lot of people in the southern
states agree they're like yeah you can't
do that
and like i said the worst one for
slavery was mississippi and half of
those counties had banned slavery
but you couldn't stamp it out it's like
stamping out drug cartels
they were
crafty they had a lot of money
and they knew how to skirt things and
they could take
control of a county and in those days a
county was like a state
a state inside of a state
the counties were kind of sovereign in
some of these states
a county could be in a state and tell
the state government [ __ ] off
because they democratically decide to do
something in there and that's it
it's just the way it was back then and
you really
the federal government for the most part
had no teeth it could talk all it wanted
but it really couldn't make much happen
um
there was just no way to enforce
anything really
murder hornet said just doing a little
smack lol
[Laughter]
all
yeah
hey i mean you know you do you so this
is the background where this dude came
from
and that was nothing that [ __ ] that
some of the some of the union and some
of the northern states or some of the
union states had slaves but they were
in the war or stayed out of it
maryland stayed out or they or they were
in or they stayed out of it didn't they
they basically stayed out of it although
they were just kind of like well we yeah
like the people here like it's
technically illegal to hold slaves there
but it's like they didn't really want to
go with the confederacy but they were
basically saying well i don't know i'll
get into that in a little bit but some
states only declared war against other
states
that's another weird thing that happened
like some southern states says yeah
we're going to go to war but we're not
going to go to the war with all the
union we're just going to go to war with
that particular northern state that we
have a problem we just don't like we
don't like that
right and we don't like new jersey right
well it's usually something in
particular usually
that they had some kind of a trade
dispute with
or or a history
of problems with that other states this
is where we're going to go to war but
we're only going to go to war with that
state although that didn't actually
happen on the battlefield and in
practicality everybody had to fight
everybody that's what really happened
danny rowling said was there a possible
chance that john wilkes booth could have
got away if he had planned better or had
help he did have help
he had several
co-conspirators
and he had a bunch of people like that
were confederate sympathizers that
helped him along the way
and yet he he did like you know get away
for a little while but they eventually
caught up with him and i think the weird
thing about this one of the and i saw
this pointed out like on a documentary
that i watched about him
that they're like one of the interesting
things about john wilkes booth as an
assassin was that a lot of assassins
that you see
um you know it's like oh i'm gonna kill
the president or whatever it's like they
usually do it
to be famous
um john wilkes booth was already famous
he was so famous
that
everybody knew what the [ __ ]
looked like so they knew who they were
looking for like he was famous all over
the country he was an actor
so he did it for
political reasons i mean and he was very
very clear about that like they saw all
those letters and stuff like that
because he had like a bunch of siblings
and he wrote to them and argued with
them about politics because they didn't
agree with them and all this other kind
of stuff so i don't know so like i said
it's really interesting that he didn't
really do it for fame he really did
believe
in his cause i guess
which you don't i don't know i guess you
do see that sometimes with assassins but
i kind of feel like the real high you
know the the real famous assassins they
usually just do it
for fame i feel like like to get famous
politics and this was definitely
politics because like i said he didn't
need fame and he didn't need money
because he had both of them he thought
lincoln was a was a tyrant yeah tyrant
had to die for the crimes he committed
against people that's basically you know
they absolutely believed that
um
and he also he also thought that in the
south after he did it
um that he was going to be hailed as a
hero yeah
spoiler alert that did not happen
nope nope the um
they were talking about the cottage
industry says he could back that up what
do you say right there he says he
did it uh in college i did an
archaeology uh field school at an estate
in missouri dating back to 1790 they
made everything from lead shot whiskey
cigars etc and farming yeah they made
clothes
beautiful clothes
so
slave industries were not just about
picking cotton all right
they they made every [ __ ] thing
they were skilled
laborers skilled workers and craftsmen
they could make fantastic furniture
beautiful clothing
um
just
stuff that would stand with or exceed
anything from a northern industry
um they didn't have mass production
but they all and i said earlier on the
society the way it was organized was a
lot more like feudal japan um like
tokugawa era japan
um
but they had technology
um
high technology
the south
had a [ __ ] secret weapon the best
thing that [ __ ] on the battlefield
was a southern weapon it was a [ __ ]
submarine
they had i think two of them uh one of
them was called the hundley
and it was a man powered submarine yeah
i saw a documentary about that
that was like something out of science
fiction that was something about a
science fiction it was like something
out of them
jules verne
he didn't have any engines had dudes
cranking it and it could submerge
and it could spear inside of a ship and
they'd pull back like that it would have
a torpedo or a bomb on the end of it and
it and it would pull a pull uh chain on
it and bomb and go off
which is that's probably how the homie
got sunk because it probably went off
too close and
it took water and it sank down the
bottom but they were they uh they
brought it up with all the guys in there
and coins and
little candles to burn to see how much
oxygen was in there because they didn't
the oxygen in there was just what you
had in the cabin and it was just a some
hand-powered submarine
when you looked at it it looked real
high-tech from the outside you know
looked like something built from the 30
1930s
slasher fed said we should do a show
about benedict arnold that might also be
a good show too because i saw a
documentary about him not too long ago
and he's also like a fascinating
character
and a lot more
nuanced i guess than most people well
like most things are i guess like the
more you look into stuff
so uh are we ready to kind of get into
john wilkes booth let's kind of talk
about like you know i know that some of
our probably most of our uh crowd is
americans but i feel like we do have
like a lot of uh you know listeners that
aren't americans so i don't know how
familiar they are i mean i'm sure
everybody is familiar with like the
assassination of
of abraham lincoln but
i don't know how much people know about
john wilkes booth as a person or how
what like what the context was like for
all of that [ __ ] happening and stuff
like that so
we'll get into all of that as we go
along
so john wilkes booth now like i said he
came from
a large family of very very prominent
actors like his dad whose name was
junius brutus booth
was super famous he was like a
shakespearean actor in europe
now there was kind of a big scandal
because in england john wilkes with his
dad he was married obviously but he had
a mistress and he basically says to the
wife by and like he
came he immigrated to the united states
with the mistress
and then him and the mistress i think
didn't get married until like 13 years
later or something like that so like i
said there was kind of a big scandal
because he was like super famous so they
moved to the us in june uh 1821 and
bought 150 acre farm now this is where
bel air near bel air maryland and this
is where john wilkes booth was born now
he was actually i believe he was the
eighth or ninth of ten kids you know had
a lot of kids back then but i don't
think all of them you know live till
adulthood i think maybe only six of them
did that happened a lot back then
so uh so as a kid uh john wilkes booth
was actually quite popular uh very
athletic he rode horses he did fencing
he did all that kind of stuff
now he went to school uh until he was a
teenager and most of his teachers said
yeah he's a smart kid but kind of a
slacker like he doesn't really uh i
think one of his teachers said not
deficient in intelligence but
disinclined to take advantage of the
educa educational opportunities offered
him
so a slacker that's what he thinks so
not dumb but it's lacquer
uh he also went to like a quaker school
for a little while like a boarding
school but after his dad died when he
was 14 he actually ended up leaving
school
now one this i always found this really
interesting but one kind of um
anecdote that's often told about his
youth is that when he was a teenager
he apparently went to a fortune teller
who read his palm
and said that he was going to have a
very like awesome but very very short
life like you're going to die young and
you're going to meet a bad end she said
to him
and apparently he was real obsessed by
this whole thing his sister said he
wrote that [ __ ] down and kept it in his
pocket like all the time and every now
and then he would like pull it out and
look at it so i don't know if it was
some kind of weird self-fulfilling
prophecy or whatever but he was really
into
the idea that he was gonna die young you
know what i mean
so when he's 16 years old um he's
getting interested in the theater like i
said he comes from a a prominent like
acting family like his dad was very
famous and his uh brother edwin booth
was also like also super famous probably
even more famous than that than his dad
was
and so he starts uh getting into theater
and stuff like that he also gets into
politics right about this time
now he gets involved with the know
nothing party
uh who was basically
they're deplorable they're anti well
they're anti-immigrant anti-catholic
particularly there was like that kind of
thing yeah so he got hold on i want to
say something
okay
save your spot right there so you don't
see don't forget where you are
the clan always comes in to focus when
you talk about
after the civil war
some people might say well damn wilkes
john will's booth that might have been
some kind of a clan type operation
because the klan was around
people don't realize that the main enemy
of the clan didn't have anything to do
with black people or
had to do with catholics
they [ __ ]
were terrified of catholics
which is just something there was a lot
of anti-catholics they were [ __ ]
terrified well like i said the no
nothing but but i feel like it usually
went together like and like racism
anti-immigration anti-catholic
that usually went together
yeah well the catholic thing is is that
they thought the catholic church was
conspiring to overthrow the u.s
government
all right
yeah that's what ben frail just said
that the pro-masonic party yeah they got
their nickname know nothing because they
always said they knew nothing about
freemasons infiltrating political
options yes
there may have been something to all
this all right there may have been
catholics trying to
take over the government because like i
said protestants were trying to and
we're doing it
so you know and and masonic type people
so they had secret societies back then
they were like little miniature gang
wars or cartels just they were more more
based in
loyalty and information than they were
selling drugs or [ __ ] bringing people
you know smuggling people across borders
and then the immigration thing you know
they were talking about immigration from
europe because they were afraid that
catholics would use weaponized
immigration to bring in more catholics
so they could [ __ ] vote themselves
into power and throw
throw
you know what uh you know non-catholics
out so there may have been something to
all this all right they believed it was
true
both sides
were casting dispersions like that on
each other may have been something to it
because back in those days everything
was ethnically based it just all that's
how people are were you know a lot of
people still are like that
so and they were like that back in
europe
so so it's just
like i said
the war between north and south started
way back in the hockey motherland
they were fighting back before the war
back they were fighting when they were
still all back in europe they were
fighting so
there's some to all these [ __ ] what
they call conspiracy theories yeah
there's some to it
yeah well i mean i kind of think that
sometimes there's a kernel of truth to
it i don't usually think that it's as
egregious as like some people think it
is but i mean sometimes it is obviously
but
i think it's pretty rare for that to
happen but i mean the ideas don't
usually come from nowhere unless it's
something about bigfoot being from space
or some [ __ ] like that obviously that's
stupid part of the reason why the united
states is
is the way it is now in terms of the way
if everything is
decentralized and there's still 50
states and there's a district of
columbia which is where they meet up if
you look at the way it was all set up it
was set up
so
all these warring factions could kind of
have their own territory and have their
own say so
over the their own places and that they
could contribute in in a centralized
government to where that government
could not oppress a state
uh and it was all these checks and
balances
to stop them from doing what they wanted
to do which is take over
everybody wanted to take over
the
the thinking was very sound
very sound for the time keep it keep it
don't you
keep it so there's no way that
one person could take over and tell
everybody else what to do because they
all hated each other
none of them agreed with each other they
were all from somewhere else
yeah well
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do
yeah
uh so yeah so that's kind of when he
first started getting so he first got
involved with the no nothing party a
little bit
so then he starts on his acting career
which like i said was actually ended up
being very successful he actually made
his stage debut when he was 17 years old
in 1855.
now uh he kind of got like uh heckled
when he [ __ ] up but you know it was
the first time leave him alone
now he also started acting at a
theater in baltimore
called the holiday street theater which
was actually owned by john t ford who
would later go on to do the ford's
theater which is where
uh abe lincoln was assassinated and it's
a whole thing where like uh you know
booth actually like did a bunch of
shows there so he was very familiar with
that uh theater which is one of the
reasons why he chose that for the
assassination
so basically uh he actually first
started out like it feels like he wanted
to make his own way like without trading
on his very very famous family because
like i said his both his dad and his
brother were very famous actors so at
first he was always billed as jb wilkes
but
uh one thing this is funny
and i'm not sure if this means what i
think it means
but they're talking about uh
about him about booth as an outrageous
scene stealer
and that he played his parts with
heightened enthusiasm and i was like
does that mean he was like a total ham
because i feel like that's probably what
they mean like he was just a total ham
but apparently like audience aided
audiences ate it up though like it
seemed like after a couple of times like
where it was kind of rough at first it
seemed like everybody was really into it
like they said he was like super
energetic and he's like rushing around
and like doing sword fights and like he
was just real like i said he was a ham
but people loved it i kind of feel like
um this is very funny to me so he was in
hamlet with his brother i was this is
one of very few times that he was
actually on the stage with his brother
edwin who like i said was already very
famous
he says he's in hamlet uh he was horatio
and edwin was in there
and when it was over like his brother
edwin comes out
and says i think he's done well don't
you and everybody clapped i was like i'm
not sure if i'd be like [ __ ]
charmed or mortified if my brother did
that like it's you know
look at my little brother he did good
and he did good everybody clap for him
and i was just kind of like okay
uh so at this point
he was getting like i said he was
getting pretty famous
and
there were some newspapers that called
him the handsomest man in america which
that seems a little bit like hyperbole
but i mean he wasn't a bad looking dude
i mean you know but
and i you know i never saw him alive i
didn't see him moving around or nothing
like that but you know maybe that helped
but he looks like a pretty good looking
fella like from his pictures
and uh
you know
so there's that
so basically uh he starts
you know from acting he actually made
like a [ __ ] ton of money
he got to a point where he was earning
you know back then at twenty thousand
dollars a year which is about 600 000 a
year in today's money which is amazing
like for stage acting i mean i know they
didn't have tv and movies and [ __ ] like
that so you kind of had to be an actor
on the stage because there wasn't any
such thing as movies but
i mean a half a million dollars more
than half a million dollars a year
that's uh that's not bad that is a lot
of money
so he and he would go on national tours
he would do all this other kind of stuff
now so when the civil war started in uh
april of 1861
booth was doing a show in albany new
york
and he was uh not shy about
kind of throwing his lot in with the
south saying you know the south seceding
saying that he thought it was heroic
now the fact that he
said that i'm not really sure if he said
it on stage or if he just said it like
publicly where other people heard him
but enough people heard him that they
got pissed off
and um basically they wanted to
ban him from the stage is that what what
happened
oh i was gonna say
he dropped his glass in the sink and
broke it
was like what the [ __ ] i hear all this
goddamn
geez
yep
all right so where was i okay so
yeah so the fact that he called the
south seceding heroic uh people in
albany new york were not having it and
they were like yeah we'd like they
wanted him booted off the stage because
they thought they were treasonable
statements
um but the critics still loved it they
didn't really they're like what he's a
great actor it's like they weren't
really all that worried about it
now uh at this point too it does seem
like even though the civil war was going
on and he was a confederate uh
sympathizer
he seemed to be like mostly
appearing in border states which like i
said maryland was um and also in union
states so
i guess and he couldn't he seemed to
have a hard time keeping his mouth shut
about stuff too so it kind of got him in
trouble
so basically he's going like all over uh
you know all over the us like doing
his doing his thing like being on stage
and everything like that he got like fan
mail the whole [ __ ] deal i think i
read somewhere too that
he was so famous that he was one of the
first people that they actually recorded
that women would like mob him and like
try to like tear parts of his clothes
off and [ __ ] like that so there's that
so as i mentioned earlier uh his friend
john t ford who owned another theater uh
opened ford's theater again where abe
lincoln would be assassinated uh in
that same year like so they were friends
and this was in washington dc
and booth was actually one of the first
leading men to appear on the stage there
interestingly he was in a play called
the marble heart and abe lincoln himself
came and saw the play like from his box
now the story goes that during the
performance that booth was in
um
booth like
he was saying a line and like pointed up
at lincoln and like shook his feet like
wagged his finger at him or some [ __ ]
like that
and apparently uh his sister-in-law who
was also in the box with him like turned
and said uh yeah he looks like he's
pointing at you bro kind of thing
and uh abe was like yeah he's he does
seem like he's looking pretty sharp at
me he said so like i said he wasn't
making a big secret about his hatred for
abraham lincoln
so uh there was another occasion too
where lincoln had a son named uh tad
and tad went and saw john wilkes booth
because like i said he was really really
famous and he was like in all these
plays like around town and everything
and tad was like really he was a big fan
like he was just like wow he was so
great and he wanted to um you know it's
like
[ __ ]
he like booth actually gave the kid a
rose right and then like they were like
lincoln's invited him to the white house
and he's like nah he was he wouldn't go
i mean i think he did take the rose from
the kid but you know what i mean he
wouldn't go to the white house even
though he was invited so you know
and basically i think like the last um
acting gig that he did was actually at
ford's theater in 1865.
now as i said he was making a [ __ ] ton
of money as an actor so he started
investing during the early 1860s so he
did like some land speculation
in boston and he also started a business
developing oil wells in pennsylvania
now although these oil wells were
initially very successful like they had
a good yield at first
but they decided like him and he had two
other partners as well
and the partners decided uh hey we need
to like increase these wells output
let's
let's explode some [ __ ] like let's use
some explosives and it didn't work out
so good so then it just kind of uh all
the production was ended by their
by their blowing up everything yeah i
was walking into the bathroom and set my
drink down and it caught the edge of the
sink and it popped the bottom of the
glass right off and it all fell down
into this thing
holy [ __ ] yeah i lost my jar i had to go
down get another jar
then i lost that ice
you know how valuable a jar is here
[Laughter]
like we have [ __ ] tons of jars come on
and we buy things in jars all the time
and i got mason jars yeah i was gonna
say you got all kinds of jars cause you
mostly drink out of those because i
don't drink out of them because they're
too big for my hands i'm gonna start um
when that uh when those tomatoes really
start rocking when tomatoes start coming
in i'm gonna make tomato sauce and i'm
gonna cook it in there
jar it preserve it in jars
like tomato sauce yeah yeah man
yeah that way you know
because i know when those things start
coming in i don't want that sauce to go
bad
remember last time when tomatoes started
to come in and i couldn't eat them all
yeah we're gonna see okay we're gonna
see oh yay some sauce out of that you
know
that'd be pretty good yeah cook it in
the jar there you go cook it outside the
jar and then put it in jar cook it again
yeah
yeah so uh okay so at this point uh you
know he has all this money he has all
these other businesses and [ __ ] like
that um the south isn't doing too good
in the civil war and lincoln got
reelected
so this really really pissed him off
so he basically withdrew from his big
oil business um and lost a bunch of
money like probably about eighty
thousand dollars uh you know give or
take maybe a little bit more than that
in today's money i mean
and uh so as i said booth was a big fan
of slavery big fan uh and was very very
opposed to the abolitionists he hated
hated hated
abolitionists and he even kind of like
went in disguise
to go see
uh john brown the you know the abolition
abolitionist leader he went to see him
hanged in 1859
um you know and he was like real excited
about going to do that like i said he
had to sneak and he like he had to like
put on disguise and [ __ ] like that
so uh so when lincoln got elected the
first time 1860.
the
after not too long after that happened
booth had written this big long speech
which i don't i don't know if it was he
ever gave it anywhere
but he wrote it all down anyway
and he's basically like um
he really did not like the northern
abolitionism he really did not like i
mean he was very into the south he was
very into slavery and when the civil war
began uh and 11 of the southern states
seceded from the union but maryland
where booth had been born was against uh
they held slaves but they
didn't want to join the confederacy
um
i it it does seem like some of the
population wanted to join the
confederate confederacy but when they
did the legislature the legislature
voted on it and they pretty decisively
like voted not to want to say something
else
in those days
being pro or anti-slavery
didn't always mean okay
didn't didn't always mean what you think
it meant
there could be a person who could
would be pro-slavery but then
then they would say but slavery is
immoral we shouldn't be doing it
then they would say why they
why he supports it though like they'd be
saying
you you some of them would say
slavery is
is an inhuman practice it's barbaric
from another era we shouldn't be doing
it but i support it now
i support it now because the south has
no industries if slavery goes away
all of the wealth of the south will go
away and the rich people will be as poor
as the poor people and then there will
be no one to help the poor people and
the and the south will not be able to
claw its way out of will not have any
money to claw its way out of poverty
which will mean that the north will come
in
with their money and take over and we
will lose our our country that's what
they would say
and and they would believe that
true to that that is true that's what
would happen
so just because somebody supported
slavery didn't mean that they approved
of it
all right now here's another angle you
have some people that's
would
would say i do not approve slavery you
know
i do not approve of slavery and he says
but it's not that i
disapprove of slavery because i think
it's inhuman
i disapprove of slavery because it's
keeping white people poor
these black people need to be sent back
to where they came from
there was that too
so the issues are not clear cut about
just
just if a per
like you could have a person who was not
racist supporting slavery and a person
that was racist supporting the abolition
of slavery
okay the the way they talked about this
in their writings is very different from
what you would think of today
as arguments for it you know
so there was a lot of a lot of the
abolitionists were also anti-black
that's what i'm trying to get at
so don't color when she's telling you
these stories you can't color it with
modern thinking these people did not
think the way modern people do they had
their own motives for thinking the way
that they thought
well everyone always does yeah it's
always like whenever in the context of
the context of the time in the context
of that individual people they had black
people who owned plantations and owned
black slaves
just
because they didn't think of it as a
racial thing per se they just thought it
was a money thing
but that existed
yeah well as we always always point out
in the show everything's a lot more
complicated more complicated than things
seem on the surface you know what i mean
so uh to that end like i said
because maryland's uh legislature had
voted against uh secession
they also voted
not to allow federal troops to pass uh
through to pass through uh the state by
rail
and they wanted lincoln to take out all
the federal troops that were stationed
in maryland so i kind of feel like
maryland wanted to kind of have it both
ways where they wanted to like stay in
the union but they also didn't want to
really get involved like with fighting
the south you know what i mean so
they're kind of that's why they call
them border states because they were
just kind of like ambivalent i guess
they kind of wanted to play both ends i
guess that's what he was trying to do
so uh the thing about it though is that
because maryland's legislature voted
that they didn't want their
rail system
used um to fight the south
meant that dc was basically like exposed
you know what i mean because it's like
that's
kind of the only way to get there torp
sort of thing
so uh one of the things and like i said
it wasn't just that john wilkes booth
was like a big fan of slavery which he
was because he brought it up like many
many times like in his writing and stuff
but
another thing that lincoln did that
pissed him off was because of this whole
situation like what happened in maryland
um
what ended up happening was that lincoln
suspended the writ of habeas corpus and
imposed martial law in baltimore and in
other parts of the state too
and put a lot of the maryland political
leaders uh in prison like at fort
mchenry like kind of imprison them
and uh things like that so
some people thought that was
unconstitutional and so that was another
thing they thought it was like overreach
for like the federal government so it
wasn't just
that there was like a whole bunch of
other like issues going on as well
now i guess like for a time
uh john wilkes booth actually
went around and like he was still doing
his acting thing in the north and the
south uh i believe he went down to even
new orleans and did some stuff too while
he was doing this stuff
apparently he um smuggled quinine
to the south because i guess there were
embargoes and stuff like that and you
know the soldiers down there needed it
because it's you know to fight malaria
and uh so he was trying to get it past
the blockades and all that kind of stuff
so apparently he did that as well at
least that's what he told his sister
because she actually wrote
his sister wrote um
uh an autobiography later on and she had
like a bunch of stuff about him because
she had written to him a lot and had
like some letters from him and stuff so
she wrote like uh some stuff about that
all right
so where was i
now as i said booth was really really uh
pro-confederate
his family though uh was divided
he was very outspoken like i said you
couldn't shut him up about it he's you
know like that uncle that rants at
thanksgiving that you never want to
invite he was like that i'm imagining
um now interestingly his brother edwin
uh was an abolitionist and absolutely
refused to uh do stage performances in
the south and like i said edwin was
probably more famous than his brother
was
and uh just because he disagreed with uh
the whole thing so much and he was just
like no i'm not gonna do it so he
basically like boycotted the south
and whenever john wilkes booth would
start on the [ __ ] he'd be like and
shut it he'd be basically be like that
so uh booth actually got arrested in
1863 in st louis while he was on a
theater tour when somebody heard him say
that he wished the president and the
whole damn government would go to hell
so he got charged with uh treasonous
remarks against the government but uh
they just gave him a fine and let him go
yeah
now in uh talking bad about the
government i mean that's pretty mild by
today's standards
[Laughter]
yeah that would never even happen today
i mean yeah you can say that all [ __ ]
people say that online every single day
people say way worse than that online
and they don't get arrested so yeah
treason here's your fine
yeah yeah there's yeah you can
treasonous talking yeah yeah i don't
even think i think they just maybe put
them in a jail cell there was a lot of
[ __ ] that happened during this war that
just wouldn't fly today either
that's just one example there was a lot
of that kind of [ __ ] even worse
federal government did all kinds of
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
they were panicking because they were
flying apart
and they were trying to hold it together
and it it didn't hold
together well you know i mean there was
stuff happening on the senate floor
during that time too if i remember
correctly i don't think anybody
shot anybody that was her
are you sure about that
got a shot in there i thought they did
too but i can't remember i don't
remember if that was during the time
because i know uh president jackson shot
some dudes
he shot a dude in a duel out in front of
the white house but that was before this
that
said something about his wife if i
remember correctly
jackson was a real man all right
that [ __ ] would get drunk and
piss behind the curtains in the [ __ ]
oval office that's great he would
[ __ ] yeah during he when he wanted us
[Laughter]
he'd have he'd just invite people from
out on the street
um just invite him into the white house
and they open up big old kegs of whiskey
and they just get [ __ ] [ __ ] drunk out
of out on the front of the white house
lawn just regular public people
well you have to think and i was
watching another documentary about the
about this he was wild man well they
said that you have to think that and one
of the reasons that it was so easy for
ably to get assassinated yeah was
because really up until the early 1900s
there wasn't much security you could
walk right up surrounding yeah you could
basically was it's like what abraham
lincoln had like one dude he had like
one guy
but they're like and even the white
house
because
i guess like the the whole ideal like
the founding fathers they were like they
didn't like the whole idea of there
being all these like philanthropies of
like guards and this big complication
they didn't want to look like a monarchy
so they kind of wanted the white house
to be like the people's house they
wanted people to be like you had to like
ask you couldn't just like walk the [ __ ]
in
but you know if anybody came and
petitioned the president or something
like that they would generally let you
in and you could like air your
grievances and stuff but um you know
after this happened i kind of feel like
they're like maybe that's not such a
good idea maybe we shouldn't just let
any old rando like wander in here thank
you thank you emily and the u.s has been
through several conflicts civil
conflicts
sometimes you call it a a war between
states a civil war or revolution they've
been and we've had them of different
sizes
the american revolution was like a civil
war also and some of the stuff you've
seen in the past couple years
looked a lot like stuff from this from
the revolutionary war it got worse
in the revolutionary war
[ __ ]
loyalists had grabbed some dude and
[ __ ] beat his ass and then
uh revolutionaries had run into some
judge's house and grab him and his wife
and take them out front and tar and
feather them and burn the house down and
you know you think all that antifa [ __ ]
and everything is [ __ ] wild no it was
it's been much worse here in the past
um
but it's that same
thing and it just kind of simmers for
decades
until something happens when then it
kind of changes the dynamic and we'll
see
we'll see
but uh
things change
you know anyway uh um thank you emily i
was saying uh you all should do more
controversial historical figures super
interesting yeah we should well like i
said somebody already recommended that
we do benedict arnold which yeah yeah
that probably would be another one i
like doing history shows they're fun
well i mean i like all the shows that we
do true crime is fun paranormal is fun
history is fun we've been on the crown
and lost
benedict arnold yeah
that's all
yeah i mean but like i said it would
probably be an interesting show like i
said i saw a documentary about him not
too long ago that was actually really
interesting wasn't a bad dude per se he
just made the wrong call
yeah and i kind of feel like it like i
said it wasn't as cut and dried as
kind of history made it family was
involved in [ __ ] too there was a lot of
other complicating
factors
so uh so yeah so where were we all right
so
so booth gets arrested and then he gets
let out after paying a fine because he
made some trees in it some very very
mild trees in his statements i guess
so february of 1865 uh booth actually
becomes secretly engaged to the daughter
of a u.s senator her name was lucy
lambert hale now she didn't really know
about um his
how much he hated lincoln and all that
other kind of stuff but i don't know i
guess she thought he was hands but he
was handsome like i said and a lot of
people said that at the time and he was
like super famous
and um you know i i guess
i guess there was an issue of like
families not approving
um his mom was okay with it but i'm i
don't imagine that maybe the
the her family wouldn't be that into it
so they had to secretly get engaged
there was a i don't even know if they
ever got married or not because he
didn't live too much longer than this
spoiler alert
so
basically uh so 1864 the election is uh
you know coming like lincoln's in and
you know spoiler alert again he's going
to get reelected but even before they
knew that uh the confederacy was kind of
like um
it was looking like it they weren't
gonna win obviously
and you know the whole tide is going in
the north's favor
and it was looking increasingly likely
that lincoln was going to be re-elected
and uh john wilkes booth was not [ __ ]
having it i mean he was basically they
said he just got angry and angry and
angrier he basically blamed abraham
lincoln for every single goddamn thing
that was wrong with the south
now what ended up happening was that i
guess when the civil war had first
broken out he had promised his mom that
he would not fight in the war because
she already had she had lost like
several children like i said i think
they had ten but i think
the four of them had died or if i
remember correctly
and so she's like i don't want to really
don't want to lose anymore so please
don't sign up but he promised that he
wouldn't
but
as he got angrier and angrier he started
like thinking of himself as a coward
because he actually did want to
fight in the war which maybe was one of
the things that led him to doing what he
was doing because he was feeling like
cowardly or he was feeling like useless
i guess in some ways he didn't feel like
he did his duty he didn't feel like he
was doing what he was supposed to be
doing like he even wrote to her they
have a letter that he wrote to her and
he said um he called himself a coward
and he said he's begun to despise his
own existence so there's that
so now the first thing he now
assassination was not the first plan the
first plan was kidnapping abraham
lincoln that's what they were going to
do first
they were going to kidnap him from his
summer house
which was a few miles from the white
house they were going to smuggle him
across the potomac and they were going
to take him into richmond virginia
and then they were going to exchange him
for some
confederate uh pows
and then um he's like well
by getting all those confederate
soldiers home
and maybe like uh you know kind of
stirring up opposition to the war in the
north like they would kind of like he
thought that it would just maybe turn
the tide in their favor a little bit i
kind of feel like at that point it was
probably like way too late he's talking
about those caps but that's what he's
talking about yeah
you guys can look it up there were all
these confederate or there were union
concentration camps inside inside the
south i mean i believe most of them were
in the south
if i remember my memory isn't isn't
really working right now i think i think
they were in the south
they were [ __ ] bad places
uh looking most of those dudes they put
in there died and they died of just damn
plagues and diseases and
food was [ __ ] bad and they just kept
them in there and
i kind of feel bad for the union troops
because
even they were like why are we doing
this
you know
the war is over just let the dudes go
home they thought they would re go back
out on a battlefield and start fighting
again
which i don't think they would have
not at that not that late stage of the
war
well apparently that's what booth
thought too because he was going to
exchange a brink abe lincoln for
for
and he said oh they'll come back out and
fight for us and we'll have and we'll
like
turn the tide and i'm just like yeah
that's what i'm saying i think well i
think that as he got angry and i think
he was getting like more and more
delusional like as you went on
yeah because uh no those dudes were
those dudes didn't have anything to
fight with at that period at that point
you know by the by the ends of those
wars that just the supplies weren't
there
and they they were
they were [ __ ]
totally committed to win
in a conventional war
to prove their honor that they were
right that type of deal
so it wasn't like a
a time where you could just do terrorism
you know
that wasn't around the south would never
win in a conventional war against the
north
no
not even with good generals and we had
good generals
just couldn't do it
there wasn't enough industry there
because it would have been a long long
long long long war of attrition
to what would have happened
and uh
a decade into it it would have looked
like world war one
people like what were you talking about
it would have looked like world war one
because in certain places
it was already becoming trench warfare
and they would have done things that
similar to making machine guns and they
they had hot air balloons
for observation and artillery shells and
explosive stuff
you would have had the invention of
dynamite and plastic explosives coming
under the stress of war if you had two
fully
industrialized
nations in in north america
two of them going at each other ten
years later man
the ex the technology would have been
accelerated you'd have machine guns
before you knew it machine guns and
tanks it ended up being like world war
one
pretty quickly
but there's just no way the south just
didn't have the industrial base to do
that
so
no
look i'm [ __ ] southern all right i
understand the southern problems with
the north the south would have never won
that war never
not in the conventional war they should
have fought a [ __ ] guerrilla war it
should have been a guerrilla war and she
had a lot of politics and propaganda and
just wearing them down and
make it so it's not worth it and then
they give up and go away that's that's
how
but the south didn't think that way
they
they were trying to outdo the south
they're trying to out they were trying
to out north the north they could have
done it
so you know
booth
booth is [ __ ] tripping
yeah i kind of feel like it's really
past the point of manpower if that was
even like uh a factor from the beginning
which is the only reason the only reason
why the confederate says okay let's go
ahead and do this is because they
thought that france was going to supply
him with the weaponry and that fell
through [ __ ] quickly because
the the the union just put
a blockade in the gulf of mexico and you
know and around places so you just could
and they fought france off france
[ __ ] was gonna supply but they're not
going to fight american warships
in order you know to deliver that [ __ ]
it's like we don't care that we don't
care that much
yeah you know so the south was on its
own and it wouldn't be able to supply
itself and that that's that's why i lost
you know
so
but they should have thought that they
should have known that
that that [ __ ] france couldn't supply
them but if you look back at what was
happening
the confetti the war between the states
the southern states
their whole thing about jumping out of
the union and joining up with each other
and becoming this confederacy was all
done really at the drop of a hat it was
a very amateurish thing a lot of it was
just [ __ ] um hyperbole and [ __ ]
boisterous [ __ ] words and
uh
something you you could write in there
in the local newspaper
it was a fad more than anything else it
was like a fad
they lost their [ __ ] even their local
leaders lost their lost the ability
to think rationally when it came to what
this would take
you know oh francis gonna france is
gonna [ __ ] supply us we'll be fine
well what happens if [ __ ] the french
fall through oh well you know
god will see us through you know you
know
we're on the side or right that didn't
usually work out yeah yeah no it didn't
work that way
no
they even had a constitution they wrote
up
and it's [ __ ] ridiculous you know it
even like enshrines slavery and does
stuff
but most people have said that the
no one ever saw it really it was just
something kind of local up in richmond i
believe and
the other states didn't know anything
about it
so the confederacy didn't really know
what the confederacy was about it was
just they were just making that [ __ ] up
as they were going along
and it was all done very quickly
i kind of feel like that explains a lot
of human history yeah we're just making
[ __ ] up as well
we're not that smart some of it was
really cool though you know what i mean
their idea of dixie
you know like [ __ ] the north had
colombia which that's the
you know she's kind uh colombia is the
statue of liberty you know and
she was always some painting in the damn
saloon somewhere
some greek chick with the [ __ ] crown
and sun rays and
she was a sex pot basically you're into
drinking whiskey and yeah america
well the [ __ ] yeah
well the south broke away and they made
their own version her name was dixie and
she's like 16 year old hottie [ __ ]
you know what i mean with a little short
tunic and her little phone no daisy
dukes
she's kind of like athena basically yeah
athena
dixie is athena really
so all the songs about dixie and then
the confederate money a lot of times had
a dixie on it you know but this is all
stuff they're even making up a mythology
real quick
people are well i kind of feel like they
took a lot of well all the stuff about
colombia and stuff like that was mostly
took from the french revolution right
because they had they well they have
like a personification of liberty yeah
you know what i mean and it's usually
like a one that's kind of like yeah
well france gave us the statue of
liberty too so
they're like hey
don't [ __ ] it up yeah
as a gift yeah
uh
greenspark said that's what dixie was
yeah
dixie's basically athena
greenspark also said i read abe was
bisexual or gay could have been just
propaganda by his enemies but who knows
that seems like a weird thing to have
propaganda about back then but yeah even
if it was true it's like it doesn't
really the only one they ever heard of
that they accused being gay was buchanan
he was like one of the good presidents
because nobody ever saw him and he never
[ __ ] caused any trouble and he
did work and stayed up all
late doing work
and uh they would make fun of him call
him an old lady and you know and he was
up there with his wife
and because he had this other old man
that lived with him in the white house i
think it was buchanan i believe this was
and buchanan probably was an old queen
he got on a ballot by accident and
[ __ ] then uh
he was like he was the running mate of a
guy
and i think
that guy died or i'm gonna have to look
that up i don't remember and i think it
was buchanan it's like american history
and they never really voted for him but
he was a very popular president
he's just like oh [ __ ] i'm president oh
yeah he was a dude they just put on a
ballot to back that's about yes i better
get to work that was the ballot
and then he went to work that was 1800s
and
and by most most people the way they
read the accounts say well he's gay he
probably was
and they were they were accusing him of
it
senators were accused of
the military called him an old lady
that old lady and his husband and her
husband and her wife or they would just
do all this these gender bending
statements about them and they'd laugh
you know but this is pre-radio
pre-television so nobody knew anything
it was all just rumors in newspapers and
a lot of those rumors never traveled
outside dc so evidently americans didn't
know he was just a popular president but
probably gay i think i think it was
buchanan is who i'm thinking of
yeah i'd have to look that up i'm not
entirely sure i think i vaguely remember
something about that but yeah he's one
you don't hear that much about which i
kind of feel like in presidential terms
sometimes is probably better because he
didn't do any public speaking he didn't
have a public persona you didn't [ __ ]
anything up nobody knew who he was he
stayed in the white house
and and worked
and by all accounts and balance the
budget and he did everything that
[ __ ] was supposed to do and did
a good job [ __ ] improved everything
in terms of economy and it was because
he didn't care about his public persona
he just worked
that's the kind of president you want he
didn't want to be a celebrity
he didn't want anybody he's like i
didn't even want to be president i just
ended up in here just did it
i just got this [ __ ] job didn't did
he didn't give a [ __ ] about what the
senate said he didn't get it he didn't
give a [ __ ] you just stayed up there at
work
yeah
uh so yeah so
so initially like i said boot's plan was
they were going to kidnap lincoln so to
that end he gets a couple of his uh
buddies that he knows whose name were
samuel arnold and michael o'loughlin and
they were his accomplices and they kind
of would meet over at this woman's house
her name was maggie branson she lived in
baltimore and she was also a confederate
sympathizer so they would meet there to
like put together their kidnapping plans
so in 1864 as i said lincoln won uh
re-election in a landslide
and his big platform was uh you know a
constitutional amendment that would ban
slavery like all together and he won
very easily handily
now uh because this made john wilkes
booth so so angry uh he decided he's
gonna like pour even more energy and
even more of his money which was
substantial into this whole kidnapping
plot so he got like a whole bunch of
other people involved too like he like i
said he had help he had like
co-conspirators
uh you had a guy named david harrell a
guy named george uh azeroth a guy named
louis powell who some people call lewis
payne he used different names and a guy
named john sarat
and they also had john serrat's mom had
a like a boarding house and they would
meet there for their meetings as well
now at this point like i said uh john
wilkes booth and his family were not
really getting along most of his family
were abolitionists
and so uh it got so bad that his brother
edwin was like i never want to see you
in my house ever again get the [ __ ] out
of here he basically like told him to
[ __ ] off and get lost
but i mean he still talked to his sister
but
i kind of have a feeling that his
sister's name was asia by the way
i kind of got the feeling that his
sister would just be like
are we talking about that again because
if he seemed like the type of dude that
he would just like talk about that like
endlessly because he was always like
lincoln he sucked so much blah blah blah
she's like oh my god can we please talk
about something else yeah so it was like
uh that kind of [ __ ] i wanted to say
something though was that the dixie
chicks dropped their name because during
uh i think it was the first second gulf
war
one of those girls said something that
was uh
pissed off their fan base it was
considered to be like uh not supporting
the american troops
so all they lost all their ticket sales
that was the end of the dixie chicks so
that's why they changed their name it
didn't have anything else and the other
two members of it were [ __ ] pissed
off that that other girl said it
because they they had a [ __ ] meal
ticket they would have been doing uso
shows forever okay
most of the american army is [ __ ]
southern
the combat arms troops i thought they
just said something about bush they
don't think they said anything
particularly about the troops yeah it
was a good it was about bush but it was
it was about i don't i remember that but
i don't know it wasn't bush was it bush
yeah was it bush yeah it's about bush
but in some ways it reflected on the
troops
that was the way i remembered it but
they lost their entire fan base
so they had to change their name because
their fan base wouldn't see them
so it didn't have anything to do with
dixie
there's nothing wrong with the concept
of dixie it's just a mythological symbol
of the south that's that's all it is
greensburg said being gay was such a
ridiculous no-no for so long he had a
best friend who he lived with for a long
time
same bed but apparently that was normal
then yeah that's another thing too is i
feel like it was less weird
for
that's another thing even though
obviously they didn't really talk about
gay like they would nowadays but
it wasn't weird also for straight men to
like i said sleep in the same bed
together or be a lot more affectionate
towards one another because i've read
some letters back and forth from dudes
like back in like the 19th century and
stuff and they're very flowery flowery
like i said they're very flowery they're
very affectionate which like i said if
you wrote that nowadays people be like
bro you know what i mean they'd like
kind of look at you like but back then
it wasn't strange so i think it's more
like a cultural thing than like a
[ __ ] so it's possible
that
you know it's again it's context of the
time you know it could have just been
it's like hey this is my best bud you
know and we're just like hanging out
or they could have been gay i don't know
danny's asking me what kind of gun john
will booth use if i remember correctly
it was something like a 45 or 50 caliber
single shot
derringer i think it was just a
percussion cap derringer i believe
it was
some concealable
shot him in the back of the head at
close range
it was the derringer yeah yeah big old
[ __ ]
lead ball back in those never soft lead
ball very low animony when it hit it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] splattered man and it
broke apart
better than any modern hollow point i
mean the reason why those modern hollow
points have copper jackets is to keep
them from deforming inside the magazine
and that chambering and
you know unloading and loading you want
it to be the bullet to hold together but
if it's just gonna be a single shot
muzzle loading type situation you want
that led to be super soft when it hits
it just [ __ ]
splatters
people don't realize how much damage
those things did
you know those 50 caliber and 45 caliber
rifles that they used and just
smoothbore or rifled rifles do
sounds [ __ ] up but
i mean if they hit a bone in an arm it
blew the arm off it would just be
hanging by shreds of skin
they were [ __ ] devastating
wounds
danny rowling said you should white wig
it up for this episode
they always trying to tell me when when
to put down
i'm not drunk enough for a wig i'm
trying to hold it i don't know you're
pretty drunk no i'm not
trying to hold it together
i'm trying to hold it together for the
show
what is that ever that's never stopped
you before
how much how much how far along are we
on probably i'm right there so i'm
probably about halfway there it's not
time for a wig yet no okay so i have to
wait until again i mean we're only an
hour and 20 minutes i can't get too
[ __ ] up anyway man i'm [ __ ] under
the influence of all this damn minotaur
juice too he's
torches yeah trying you know danny
rowling said you broke a glass for
[ __ ] sake just saying
[Laughter]
it was just a freak i've broken glasses
many times when i was cold stone cold so
far yes so
just to set it down funny
next to the [ __ ] sink and knocked the
[ __ ] bottom of it off and it all
[ __ ] fell into the damn seat yeah
ghost did it that's the thing it's like
sometimes i do a lot of [ __ ] like that
when i'm stone cold server because i'm
clumsy
not just because i'm drunk like yeah
i've done dumb [ __ ] when i'm drunk too
but i do plenty of dumb [ __ ] when i'm
sober because i'm super super klutzy
so i've broken lots of things probably
broken way more things
when i was sober than when i was drunk
so uh so yeah
so booth actually went to
uh lincoln's inauguration like when he
was inaugurated the second time
and uh because i guess remember he was
secretly uh engaged to the daughter of
that senator and i guess she like you
know made him a guest or whatever i
still don't know if she well she's got
to know by now because i'm like i said
it seems like he could never shut up
about it
so um and some of the other conspirators
were also in the crowd too
now
they uh didn't attempt to assassinate
lincoln at this point
but booth said man we totally could have
you know what i mean he's like we were
right there we could have killed the
president if we had wanted to
now
when they thought that uh the next time
they were gonna try the [ __ ] was march
17th he said he knew he found out that
lincoln was gonna be uh going to a play
at uh a hospital
and he got all the team together like on
this stretch of road like near like on
the way to the hospital where the play
was gonna be and he's like okay we're
gonna kidnap him like when he comes by
right he's got his whole team there
uh but the president didn't come that
way uh turned out that lincoln at the
last minute had kind of like changed his
plans and said oh we you know we can't
go to that play we have to go to this
other reception ironically the reception
that they went to
was at the same hotel where booth was
staying at the time so you know it
almost weirdly it seems kind of like
i don't know it almost seems like this
was like weirdly faded to happen like
all of this kind of stuff like because
there was all these little details like
that i know dc is in a big town and they
kind of moved in similar circles but
yeah
so april 12th 1865
john wilkes booth hears uh that robert e
lee has surrendered at appomattox now
this
i guess it was kind of like this wasn't
officially like the end of the civil war
but they're kind of like okay it's all
over but the shouting kind of thing
so at this point booth is like well [ __ ]
he's like now um
because the union had uh union army had
taken richmond and because lee had
surrendered he's like i don't think this
kidnapping jazz is gonna work anymore so
now we're gonna have to go straight up
assassination so at that point their
plans changed
now uh so booth actually like he sounds
like a [ __ ] stalker too because
it's like not only was he at the
inauguration but he also like lincoln
gave a speech
um you know outside the white house like
after the surrender right and it was
just he hadn't written it or anything he
just came out and gave a speech and
everything
and booth came to that [ __ ] too
um and
something that he said in particular
during that speech like really really
made uh booth mad
lincoln said that he wanted to
grant suffrage to former slaves like um
you know blacks uh you know property
owner like people that he wanted to give
them the vote right
and booth was not having that
he said according to multiple witnesses
that is the last speech he will ever
make that's what he said
so april 14th 1865 booth goes to ford's
theater to get his mail because when he
was in town in washington dc because
like i said he was an actor so he
traveled around like all over the place
but when he was in dc he would uh have
his mail sent to ford's theater because
he was there so much because he was in
so many shows and he was friends with
the owner
so he goes there to get his mail on that
morning and while he's there
uh john ford's the owner's brother
says oh uh abe lincoln and mrs lincoln
are coming to a play this evening our
american cousin
um
and so and supposedly like at first it
was also supposed to be uh general like
ulysses ulysses s grant and his wife
were also supposed to be with them
so at that point booth is like ooh-hoo
and he's like okay we're gonna do the
assassination [ __ ] like tonight
now so he goes and he rents like a horse
or he makes arrangements for a getaway
horse
which
he didn't have to get a getaway car it's
1865. he had a getaway horse which uh i
know that's like it's it wasn't funny at
the time obviously but like nowadays
it's kind of funny it's like a getaway
horse so and he kind of planned out like
the how he was going to escape from
there
so later that evening uh he tells his
co-conspirators powell harold and
atzarot uh he's like we're gonna kill
abe lincoln tonight actually they
weren't actually just planning to kill
lincoln they were actually going to
assassinate lincoln they were gonna
assassinate uh the secretary of state
william seward
and they were going to assassinate the
vice president who at the time was
andrew johnson they were hoping to kind
of like cut out all three of them you
know what i mean at once it was going to
be like a three-pronged attack because
obviously all the guys were going to be
at three different places so
booth was gonna do lincoln
uh powell was gonna do seward and
azeroth was gonna do andrew johnson who
was the vp
so they had this all planned out
so what they thought that they were
gonna do uh was that they're like they
basically wanted to
take all like basically cut the head off
of the union government and like throw
everything into chaos it's so funny
they're doing this after the war not
during the war yeah i mean like like i
said technically
the war wasn't technically over
like officially over but lee had
surrendered
so you know what i mean it's just over
then that's what i mean yeah it's just
kind of like so i don't really know what
he think
i just think he got super mad
and he just kept getting madder and
madder and it almost seemed like he was
just trying to i don't know was he just
like trying to talk himself into it
i kind of feel like he almost you know i
hate to like [ __ ] psychoanalyze
people that are long dead but
he does seem to have really been [ __ ]
up by the fact that he didn't fight for
the confederacy like in the army like he
wanted to and he really felt like he
wanted to do something and then it just
seemed like he was just getting madder
and madder and madder i don't know he
just seemed like a really unhappy person
and like i only thought that it was
gonna win
and when it failed he probably said well
it's because so many guys like me didn't
actually get jump in there and fight
which he's wrong to think that it's not
why they lost
a lot of dudes jumped in there and
fought just yeah they would
never would have had the industrial base
to fuel a long war of attrition
okay
i hear people today talking about [ __ ]
happening in ukraine and they do not
understand what the [ __ ] they're talking
about
americans civilians even american
military people don't really understand
warfare that much
they're constantly trying to relive
[ __ ] um
1990 iraq that's what they treat in 91
1991 iraq over shock and all
drop some laser guided bombs [ __ ]
decapitate the government hey it's all
over
it's not how it is
warfare is a long
process of
of a treating the enemy and killing off
its fighting forces and destroying its
manufacturing capability
it takes a long time
it's almost it's almost not worth it um
it's just
and if and really if the war itself is
not genocide then why are you fighting
it
because it'll never really be resolved
the ancients
understood it a lot better
when you go to war with another country
you're basically agreeing to just wiping
them out and erasing them because if you
leave anything behind
the world will just start up again a
couple couple decades later a couple
generations later it just
you you go in there and you destroy the
damn
culture and the religion and the entire
breeding population of the country and
then you then you kind of caught you
then you take over their land
and populate it with your own people and
rewrite history as if that enemy never
existed that's really
how ancient people did it
so there's no memory of those people
that works anything else is a half
measure you're just inviting attack
later
an endless cycle of it
this bet is horrible process
so the best thing to do is don't do it
okay don't
don't worry about it learn how to
[ __ ] live with other people you know
learn how to work things out agree to
disagree on certain things
don't try to
tell other people what to do don't tell
other people how to live it it never
really works out
it doesn't really matter either side
but when it came to the south you could
have never won a conventional
war against the north at that at that
period in time
now
i'm sure lee and all those guys knew it
it must have been trying to fight for
some kind of agreement
but the germans tried that and they
[ __ ] lost and germany as those
germans knew it [ __ ] never existed
again
that was the same thing the japanese did
we're doing that you know now uh
the japanese thought that if they
attacked pearl harbor it would scare us
off
[ __ ] their best generals said no
you're [ __ ] insane those those
americans have come back and they'll
next thing you know they'll be here on
our home island
yeah and that's exactly what happened
you know
there are no half measures in this [ __ ]
it's like saying i'm gonna half kill
that dude
you know what i mean
you're gonna half kill that dude what
happens when he heals back up
you know
he's gonna come beach yeah right right
so
danny rowling said uh was he a freemason
not that i ever heard
john wilkes booth yeah i don't think so
um but yeah so the ironic thing about
them thinking that they were gonna take
out
the top three what they thought was like
the three main heads of the hydra i
guess
um is that
one of the people they were like seward
one of the people they were planning on
killing was actually not
the next in line you know what i mean um
that actually would have been
the uh lafayette foster who was the
what do they call it the president the
pro-tempore whatever of the senate
so yeah they didn't even like talk about
assassinating him
uh also they were thinking hey if
ulysses s grant
is at the play too because initially
like he was supposed to be with lincoln
and his wife um then we can get him as
well but
he um him and his wife actually ended up
not coming for whatever reason um i
guess now i've heard that it's because
ulysses s grant's wife and mary todd
lincoln hated each other but i don't
know if that's true or not so i don't
know if like the wife was just like i'm
not gonna go sit with that [ __ ] so i
don't know i'm just imagining but i've
heard that's why but they don't know
that's why
so the thing about it like i said the
reason why i thought this whole thing
was kind of like it's almost like too
perfect was because
lincoln happened to come to a play at
ford's theater that evening
booth had performed many many many times
at ford's theater like knew the place
like the back of his hand and nobody
would think it was weird that he was
like walking all around there like i
said he was very good friends with the
owner he had his mail delivered there so
he had every
right to be like walking around like
wherever
in the place because it's like
everybody's like hey it's john wilkes
booth everybody knew who the [ __ ] he was
he was famous so nobody thought it was
weird that he was walking around there
so um
now earlier in the day he actually did
kind of go because everybody knew like
which uh box was lincoln's so he did
actually kind of go up there and sort of
rig it so that when he got into the box
like he'd be able to like bar the door
so nobody could come in after him um
some sources say that he drilled a
little borehole like in the door so he
could kind of look through there but
later on i think they found out that no
the owner had actually done that so the
guard could look in and make sure there
was no shenanigans like going on or
whatever but so i don't really know i
don't know if the owner bored that
earlier or if booth did it but you know
so there's that but so that was one of
the things they said that he'd like
planned ahead of time but i don't know
if that's true
now uh so booth goes to a bar
before the assassination i guess trying
to get some dutch courage up in there
and then he goes into the theater at 10
10 p.m
now while he's in the theater uh he
slips into lincoln's box at around 10 14
p.m as the play was going on now
interestingly uh i
have read that he knew the play our
american cousin i don't know if he'd
ever actually been in it but
it seems like he had been in it because
he knew it like pretty intimately like
so he knew like where all the beats were
so he pretty much knew that there was
one line in the play in the third act
that got a really big laugh it's a
comedy uh that got a really big laugh
from the audience and he thought that
would be the best time
to shoot the president because no one
would really hear it all that much and
there'd be like so much noise and [ __ ]
like that so that's what he did he came
in and he waited for that line
everybody cracked up
and then he shot
so as i said it's a it was a derringer
pistol like we brought it before it says
41 caliber oh it's 41. on wikipedia all
right um but yeah so so it's small
yeah 41. yeah it was just a little yeah
40. it was a one shot yeah it's a yeah
it's a muzzle losing yeah muzzle loading
derringer i knew it was that i think it
was percussion cap muzzle loading
deranger
41 was small by those days standards 38
was tiny so was like 35
all that was 35 was almost like the 22
caliber of the day
everything was big bore
but i remembered it i
remember seeing depictions of it
it's small
you know
about the size of a real small 38
special
snub nose i like that size
you can carry it in the pocket
danny rowling said who owned the ford
theater a guy named john t ford
who was a friend of booth
so uh so yeah so boost goes up about the
president and his friend's place
[ __ ] up his friend's business i'm sure
he probably did yeah or or made it even
more famous i'm not sure it could go
either way
but yeah so he just came he basically
came up and shot lincoln in the back of
the head like point blank range
um and then like everybody you know
because uh the guy that was actually in
the
you know was supposed to be ulysses s
grant and his wife but they couldn't
come
so it was actually a major henry
rathbone
who was in there uh with his i believe
with his wife as well
so there was actually kind of like a
scuffle after this and booth ended up
stabbing rathbone i think even either in
the arm or in the shoulder um he
survived but like you know the guy was
like trying to lunge at him or whatever
and um yes it was rathbun's wife i guess
fiance her name was clara harris and she
was okay like nothing happened to her
but uh rathbone got stabbed
so then booth very famously jumped out
the president's box onto the stage now
either
the story goes that either his spur got
caught on like there was like flags like
draped over the um the boxes or it was
because of him struggling with uh with
rathbone
but he fell like 12 feet and
most sources say that he broke his leg
or he broke his ankle when he fell onto
the stage now there are some sources
that say that he broke his leg
later
like falling off a horse or a horse
falling on him or something like that
nobody really knows
but he doesn't have gotten far with a
broken ankle or broken
he got pretty far after the shooting he
did yeah so that that's kind of why some
people say that he i mean he did break
his leg or his ankle at some point
because he went to the doctor but they
don't know if it happened like during
it's not like it hugely matters but yeah
he'd have later but he did fall a long
way
now um so what was he again 26. oh yeah
[ __ ] no young guy can fall [ __ ] from
quite a height if he's in good shape and
[ __ ] be okay long as he plfs when he
hits the [ __ ] ground no he's all
right
i'm sure he made it because if
uh you're not gonna get far with a
broken ankle and he made it pretty far
where he was supposedly killed thank you
janet
what do you say that's very nice of you
it says thanks for being you
thank you very much people thank you for
the super thank you thank you thank you
yeah ben frail said ford and his
brothers were arrested and held in jail
for a month but then let free as there
was no evidence against them whatever
yeah i don't think ford had any
knowledge of what was going on he just
owned the theater like i said he knew
booth he'd been friends with him for a
long time booth had done a bunch of
shows there he got his mail there he
knew he was coming and [ __ ] probably
well no he well he knew because he went
there to get his mail and ford's brother
said hey abe lincoln's gonna be
at a play tonight i don't know if he was
saying hey he's gonna be here shoot him
no i'm just maybe he probably just
mentioned it like just in passing you
know what i mean maybe i don't know i
wasn't there
so so yeah regardless like so he jumps
out the box like 12 feet down to the
stage now there are several
uh different
witness reports as to what he said
most sources say that he raised his
knife the one that he used to stab a
stab rathbone with and shouted sick
semper tyranus
thus always to tyrants
which is actually also virginia's state
motto
and also attributed to brutus at
caesar's assassination
uh but some people remembered that he
said the south is avenged
uh you know or i have done it the south
is avenged some people thought he said
that too but uh you know whatever it was
he was trying to make a big [ __ ]
dramatic moment about it
now uh interestingly so as i said
because they had planned to do three
assassinations this night so he had
given like his two conspiracies like i'm
gonna get lincoln you go this other
place you go this other place
so
how'd the rest of that work out not so
good uh powell who was supposed to go
get seward now seward was actually at
home in bed because he'd been in a
carriage accident so he was like you
know bedridden
and powell somehow couldn't manage to
stab a bed-ridden old man like he
stabbed him uh but the dude didn't die
like he survived
uh at zarat the other guy who was
supposed to kill the vice president
he actually didn't even bother uh he
chickened out and spent the whole night
in a bar getting drunk
so
he never even like did anything to it
so booth runs away from ford's theater
he uh jumps onto his getaway horse i
love that the getaway horse
and rides into southern maryland uh with
one of his co-conspirators david harold
and basically he was gonna go like the
back roads like as you know where where
nobody was and he knew that there was
like some other confederate sympathizers
along the way like if he needed
help or anything like that
so he also knew that there were these
kind of like uh dense forests in the
area and there was like a lot of swamps
and [ __ ] like that so he could kind of
make his way into rural virginia without
being seen hopefully
so by midnight uh booth and harold got
to sarat's tavern which is about nine
miles away
and uh prior to the assassination they
had put a bunch of like guns and
equipment and
[ __ ] like that there as kind of part of
their earlier plot like for the
kidnapping flap but they still had all
the stuff there so they're like okay
well we'll avail ourselves of that so
then they kept going south
and they stopped at a the home of dr
samuel mudd in saint catherine which is
about 25 miles from washington to see to
booth's injured leg
dr mudd later said that booth told him
the injury had happened when he his
horse fell so either he fell off his
horse or the horse fell on him so like i
said i don't know if it was the horse
falling on him or was his leg was
injured obviously i don't know if it
happened like at the when he fell off
the [ __ ] or not it doesn't really matter
so then they get to the house of another
sympathizer a guy named samuel cox this
is about four in the morning
and basically cox like calls up his
foster brother and who a guy who was a
confederate agent like in charge of spy
operations
in the southern maryland area so i think
that
kind of connection is where people are
coming up with this was like a larger
conspiracy i don't think it necessarily
was um i kind of think booth was mostly
just acting on his own him and his
co-conspirators like i said he wasn't
the fact that he went around shooting
his mouth off like to anybody that would
listen about how he wanted to kill that
[ __ ] uh really seems like he
wasn't real good on keeping [ __ ] on the
down-low so i don't really think it was
part of a larger conspiracy because why
would you hire him
one he's super famous and everybody
knows what he looks like two he can't
shut up about how much he hates abe
lincoln and how much he wants to kill
him and i don't know so i just don't
think it was part of a larger conspiracy
but i think people like point to this
kind of thing saying maybe that's what
it is
so at this point
as i said most people recognized him so
it wasn't like there was any secret
about who it was that had shot him so
they you know they put out [ __ ]
the the uh 19th century equivalent of an
apb
uh and they basically offered
and this is a big deal like at the time
a hundred thousand dollar reward
back then
uh which is almost two million dollars
today
um so yeah the big deal
so uh they kind of like sent a bunch of
federal troops out like to look through
southern maryland because they pretty
much like i said you know they got
horses and [ __ ] like that he can't get
that far so they kind of knew where he
was uh heading and there were other
people kind of like tipping them off and
[ __ ] like that
so during the days following the
assassination uh they looked through all
the woods and swamps and [ __ ] like that
like looking for him meanwhile
uh obviously the nation went into
paroxysms of grief about the killing of
abraham lincoln as i said i think that
was like really
something that
sort of demonstrated how far
gone maybe that booth was that he
actually thought i don't think that he
thought like northerners would be
excited about it but i think that he
thought that the the south would see him
as a hero
and he was very he seemed very very
surprised when that wasn't what happened
like when everybody basically came out
like calling him a monster
and
the thing about it was that even people
that hadn't particularly liked abe
lincoln were horrified by what had
happened and by what he had done and i
think he had a hard time grasping that
reality
uh at least according to
everybody that knew him at the time that
like saw his reaction they said that he
was like really surprised because he
thought that people would
think it was cool i guess
well it's kind of like jack ruby jack
ruby shot lee harvey oswell
and he thought that he would go down in
history as a hero
that's not what really happened
and uh some people would say well the
cia must have put
or this or the mob may have put
you know jack ruby up to killing lee
harvey oswald
i kind of thought that but then the more
i found out about the [ __ ] jack ruby
now jack ruby killed lee harvey oswald
because he loved jfk he just did
and he [ __ ] wanted to kill the man
that killed his president
and he thought that everybody would
[ __ ] see him as a [ __ ] hero for
killing the man that killed a good
president
same thing
same kind of thing this guy thought he
was a jack ruby yeah i killed the bad
guy yeah you have to understand i mean
you you will you see lincoln as a hero
not these guys okay well he didn't
obviously yeah but i think that he
thought that more people thought of
lincoln as a villain than they did
yeah well
here's another thing that people have a
hard time coming to grips with
lincoln was not a popular president
during his lifetime he ended up becoming
popular after his death and over time
but uh even even other republicans
evidently didn't like lincoln or lincoln
too much
i mean i think he did a good job under
the [ __ ] dire circumstances that the
us that the union was under at the time
but he evidently was not real
likable
on a personal level they said he was
kind of mentally kind of
glitchy um
he was spending a lot of his time in
hiding he may have had some mental
problems
definitely it was under a lot of stress
they'd say his wife was a lunatic i
don't really know much about his wife
um
she was all i know much about her was
that she was real into spiritualism but
i i think that kind of happened after he
died which is not really that the union
flew apart under his watch even his own
side kind of blamed him for some of this
[ __ ] which i think they wrongly blamed
him but you know what i mean the buck
stops with the presidency so a lot of
that [ __ ] fell on him he was kind of
ended up being an american hero and a
republican hero in hindsight
after all those monuments monuments were
made and
certain temperatures got cooled off and
the [ __ ] union started to come back
together he was kind of
became a symbol of uh
americanism
so i think i think uh i think booth
thought he was killing a tyrant and that
he would be a hero
he did seem to think that but like i
said so
because he was in hiding like i said for
for a while and they would bring him the
newspapers
and you know they put lincoln's body
like they took it on a tour like a
funeral tour essentially like all around
the country and they said [ __ ] man like
thousands and thousands of thousands of
mortars came and everybody was just
freaking out they were just kind of like
really really upset about it and so
i think he was really surprised that
lincoln was as beloved as he was and
that even you know even robert e lee and
people like that came out and said man
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that like
somebody shot him and i wasn't even on
the same dudes the dude's side or
anything like that but
i think that booth really seemed
surprised that
that everybody didn't i don't think he
thought everybody was gonna herald him
as a hero but i think that he thought
the south would see him as a hero like
he thought he was doing his duty and i
think he was really like shocked when
that didn't happen
yeah i mean i think you know a lot with
a lot you know a lot with booth you know
and a lot of southerners they were
[ __ ] very upset what happened during
sherman's march you guys can [ __ ]
read up on that you know
atlanta burned to the ground and a bunch
of [ __ ] you know
a lot of those union troops didn't
behave too well when they got here a lot
of those union troops really weren't
really weren't all that american a lot
of them were [ __ ] irish straight off
the [ __ ] boat didn't even speak
english they're still speaking gaelic
and they're handing them [ __ ] rifles
and sending them towards the south and
then you know what the fighting's about
there's just you know
but they don't blame them you know what
i mean they're just
soldiers gonna do what he's told to do
but there are a lot of abuses on the
south
during that war
the southern civilians
got caught in the middle and you might
have union troops burning down
somebody's [ __ ] house and raping the
women and those people [ __ ] were
anti-slavery people you know it was just
war is [ __ ] chaos this history comes
in and [ __ ] tells these stories and
cleans it all up
uh but when you have [ __ ] hundreds of
thousands of men under arms just running
around
kind of doing whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do
in the name of whatever ideology they
think is right all kinds of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happens
and
you got guys like booth saying all this
i'm going to avenge the south
and he's got his own take on it and he's
gonna [ __ ] do what he wants to do
everybody else is dying he's gonna
[ __ ] risk his own life it's kamikaze
type mission
it was [ __ ] chaos
you know it was [ __ ] chaos another
thing that i think he didn't really
think through or take into consideration
was that even
people in the south that
hated lincoln and didn't agree with his
policies
um once the civil war was over once lee
had uh you know surrendered and lincoln
got shot
then the southerners were like [ __ ] you
bud now they're gonna like take even
more revenge against us and [ __ ] us up
even more
so in a way it was like lose lose for
everybody
he didn't really think through the
consequences i feel like and there were
there were also republicans in the south
you know people forget that
if you if you watch um
free state of jones free state of jones
was
that that uprising against the bathroom
against the union and then the
confederacy after that
um was it was a republican
[ __ ] uprising
of [ __ ] freed blacks
uh slaves that have been freed and
whites
uh fighting against the confederacy
inside jones county mississippi
uh [ __ ] excellent movie
but there were there were republicans in
the south that supported
uh the union and uh and liked
uh
uh
[ __ ] what the hell
they like the president so
it wasn't as clear-cut as as you know
people want to paint it
yeah mary todd lincoln did did seances
and stuff yeah i'd also [ __ ] uh
remember
hearing accounts
of that she was real mentally unstable
too um
i can't remember exactly what it was
but uh she might have been kind of a bit
of a lunatic
yeah i remember she just yeah and she
probably had some problems i mean she
had what was it was it crying fits or
laughing fits or well like tammy pointed
out i think it was tammy said earlier
that she had uh yeah depression she
probably did which like i said they
probably really didn't know much about
back then and to be honest i think we
talked about her a little bit maybe on
one of our spiritualism shows i feel
like
um
or something because i do kind of feel
like she had kind of a rough life where
she like lost a kid or lost a couple
kids and that kind of like [ __ ] her up
you know what i mean which like i said i
understand that that's that's
yeah some have said that lincoln
may have had more fan syndrome but i i
don't believe so
i've heard that too but
i don't know like like i said it's hard
to like diagnose [ __ ] usually if
somebody somebody's lost syndromes
they're also sterile
if i remember correctly and i think he
had kids didn't he
yeah yeah
so how could he have had more fan
syndrome i thought if you had more fan
syndrome you were basically sterile i
would have to look it up i don't know
like offhand
okay
i don't know offhand i've seen
photographs of him though he looked
normal to me
he's super tall but a lot of people are
super tall right so you know it's not
that weird
but um
but yeah so i i just kind of feel like
like i said he didn't really think it
through and i feel like even
even people that were maybe secretly
glad that lincoln got killed
were not gonna say it out loud
because like i said they just got
[ __ ]
[ __ ] up in the war they just lost and
it's like they're not gonna say it out
loud because they're gonna get in even
more trouble
yeah you know
so i don't know
i kind of i kind of feel like it just
i don't i don't know
and i was watching a documentary about
this earlier and they they were kind of
speculating on
would things have been better
if you know lincoln like just in general
if lincoln had not been assassinated
you know would things have worked out i
mean obviously it would have worked out
differently but like how would it have
been different like how
you know i mean because what ended up
happening after the civil war
was you had you know the south right and
all the jim crow laws and [ __ ] like that
and it's like would that have happened
the same way
i've heard people i've heard people
mostly lean kind of progressive were
saying that well you know if the civil
war didn't happen the south would be a
different country would still have
slavery
no not true
slavery was going extinct throughout the
entire world around the same time
brazil had slavery they had they had a
lot of it i think probably more than the
united states did
and it faded away and became obsolete
about a decade before
a decade or two before uh it went
obsolete here and it didn't even take a
war to do it
um it's just that
slavery is always associated with
poverty
uh if you have a civilization that has a
high poverty rate in it there's probably
going to be slavery in it
um
that's going to start to use that as to
fuel an economy and then it starts a
fueling poverty because it just sucks
all profit out of everything it's a it's
a [ __ ] non-functional system
as technology starts to increase
profitability starts to increase slavery
becomes
obsolete and goes away
you know the people because it becomes a
detriment to prosperity
and
so no you does not take a civil war to
get rid of slavery
the end of slavery is more associated
with technological
technological advance well that's what
gets rid of i wasn't even talking so
much about slavery i was talking more
about like reconstruction and stuff like
that like how would [ __ ] have worked out
differently
and and like i said the the jim crow era
and stuff like that would that have
worked out differently had he not been
assassinated
no you've been the same you know it'd
have been the same that's what i'm
saying i don't really know if it would
have been different or not
but i was just it's somebody brought it
up like on a documentary i saw earlier
and i'm like that i thought that was
kind of like an interesting question
because i think that when booth did it
and he even said after he did it like
after he was on the run and everything
like that he wrote
um
in his journal that he didn't regret it
so
but i like i said i still think that he
was shocked to find out that he didn't
have
public opinion on his side i guess
like i think he thought that he was
going to get more support than he got if
you were to be able to rewind history
and replay it and look at all the
possible timelines
the way that [ __ ] went down
was one of the
worst ways it could have gone down there
were a lot of other ways where it could
have gone down a lot better without that
civil conflict
all right and even in in any one of
those situations
slavery still would have been
rendered obsolete the only difference
would have been a matter of a few
decades
because it was going extinct everywhere
around the world yeah around that same
time
and it was because of technological
advances
it's always associated with that
janet says uh yes because johnson who is
the vice president uh came in after was
the one who pushed the reconstruction
not lincoln's plan yeah so that's what
i'm saying like how like it would have
played out different had he not been
like pro i don't know
it probably would have been better but i
don't really know there's two there's
too many facts another thing is is that
we're always focusing on the political
parties and the leaders involved
america america's not a monarchy
all right
it's not even a dictatorship in a way a
dictatorship might even be better than
what america is america's has always
been basically an oligarchy
those elected officials are servants of
the corporations and the big industries
that [ __ ] drive america forward
you know
the railroads the banking industry
all the [ __ ] steel mills and [ __ ]
those are the dudes that have the real
power
the presidents and the political parties
do whatever those industries tell them
to do
the the
these this political party [ __ ] left
right paradigm is all artificial all
right
uh it's been placed there to give people
the illusion of a [ __ ] choice in any
of this
if it didn't if that wasn't there all
this would be gone it would have been
gone in some kind of a revolution
so
it doesn't matter
who would have been done water this and
that was really up to whatever the
industries wanted which is actually part
of what a lot of what the south's gripes
were is that they didn't have any say so
in dc because they didn't have any
industries and it was the industries
that were controlled in dc
so they were right about that
um it's just that uh they were wrong
about entering into a damn conventional
conflict with the [ __ ] north you'd
lose
now they did get a what they called a
peaceful divorce but the divorce
only held for a couple months and then
fighting broke out
and then an invasion happened
you could say oh they invaded us they're
the aggressors yeah it kind of does look
like that but that doesn't save you
from the repercussions of this damn war
there was no way you could win that
conventionally even with support from
france i don't think he'd be able to win
it
it'd be better just to let the union
just march right in just let him come in
and take over and then just do a couple
decades of this resistance and cat and
mouse and just wear them out slowly like
everybody's done to us over the [ __ ]
past [ __ ] 70 years and eventually the
north just they would just let you go
you know that's basically what we did to
england
in the [ __ ] american revolution
against england we really didn't win any
of those battles and the ones we did
they did wasn't decisive to the war
really
it was just that the v you know we
didn't really get rid of the english
until the [ __ ]
war of 1812 and they won that one they
burned down a white house in that one
it's just that eventually the british
are like man this is just too much of a
[ __ ] pain in the ass spending too
much money on these [ __ ] honkies and
they decided to just [ __ ] them let them
go just cut their legs yeah then that
that's how that's the only way the south
could have won that one and had a real
good shot at that
but the south was like i said earlier
they were not a legalistic society
and they were not a practical society
they were like something out of down
feudal japan it was an honor-based
society and they were trying to put
forth a good face and they wanted to win
this fair and square to prove to the
world that they were good people so
we're going to win this like we're
supposed to do it we're going to stand
here and just trade shots at each other
across fields
like that proves anything that you know
and then we capture their capital and
look we won just like in chess now
those cities don't matter anyway it's
just wearing somebody out
and they didn't see war that way
they hadn't evolved to that yet
and europeans are
still like that
that's not how you win wars you want to
know how to win wars ask ask the asians
okay because they'll just wear your ass
out like the vietnamese you just have to
be like a big pain in the ass just like
a big hemorrhoid can just pan yeah be a
hemorrhoid make them spend money
we could have just let the north come in
and then set up all kinds of businesses
to entertain their troops and just
sucked all the money out of them and
entertained them and sold them stuff and
then take that money to fuel guys to go
in there and just [ __ ] shoot at them
every now and then just to keep them
here and just wear them out wear them
out and then you send some guys up into
the north to go [ __ ] attack some
people in their houses and [ __ ] you know
like some senator you wipe him out and
then you just say hey got you [ __ ] you
know i just keep let us go [ __ ] and
then you're out there crying look at us
you're impressing us oh my god we're
oppressed you know just
you racist let us go you know and
eventually they just ah [ __ ] it they get
frustrated go back home
that's how you win
ben says i better get dressed i have to
be at the unemployment office in two
hours damn go get you a job man go get
you a [ __ ] job yeah good luck
good luck yeah i can't i don't [ __ ] i
don't blame you bro
yeah
uh yeah ben also said slavery is
pre-industrial wage slavery that's
practically manufacturers the north is
far more efficient yeah it's true and
indentured servitude that's even better
yeah
true
so all right so let's get back to this
because i'm not i don't have too much
more to go
so uh so yeah so booth is hiding and
he's kind of waiting to cross the
potomac into virginia and as i said like
people were bringing him newspapers
and he's kind of getting more and more
uh disheartened i guess by like how like
these big like outpourings of grief like
for the uh for the thing and like i said
everybody knew who the [ __ ] he was
because he's famous so everybody's like
that [ __ ] and he's like oh i
thought everybody would like me because
of this but i guess not and he also read
in the paper
that uh some of his co-conspirators
uh got arrested mary sarat who um you
know ran the boarding house where they
would do their uh little meetings and
stuff uh powell that guy and uh
the arnold and o'loughlin who were like
some of his early ones yeah they had
already been arrested
so there was that and like i said he was
crying in his journal about it like uh
you know i'm not sorry but i thought
everybody was gonna like think this is
cool and i guess not
but you know
so uh basically while uh lincoln's the
funeral train was doing its big thing
and like all the mourners were coming
out to see him and everything like that
um booth and harold who were still
together and they were still in hiding
they got a boat and a compass from
another sympathizer somebody that knew
them and they crossed the potomac on
april 21st
uh unfortunately even though they had a
compass they [ __ ] up and instead of
going to virginia they went back and
came
back to maryland again because they
didn't know where they were going
uh so where they got off like i guess
harold kind of you know he hunted in
this area so he kind of knew it there so
he's like oh there's a farm near here
where there's like a confederate
sympathizer we can go there and uh you
know he'll give us some [ __ ]
so they go to that place and then
there's um that guy had like a
son-in-law named john hughes not that
john hughes like the guy that directed
pretty and pink and all that
this was colonel john j hughes and he
gave him food and gave him a place to
hide out until uh nightfall and then
they were gonna like try and row across
the river again and really for real get
to virginia this time instead of uh just
turning around and ending up back in
maryland again
um
and during this time
uh he writes in his diary booth writes
in his diary with every man's hand
against me he's such a drama queen with
every man's hand against me i'm here in
despair and why
for doing what brutus was honored for
and yet i for striking down a greater
tyrant than they ever knew and looked
upon as a common cutthroat that's what
he wrote in his diary like after so like
i said he seemed like a little bit of a
drama queen
so they kind of get they finally get to
virginia
on april 23rd
and at that point they hook up with this
other guy named thomas harbin
um and he had actually they kind of
brought him into the kidnapping plot
that never happened like before they did
that
and he so he took them to another
confederate guy in the area named
william bryant who gave them horses
now at this point um they kind of i
guess like they were tipped off like uh
you know somebody knew where they were
so they sent like out 26 union soldiers
from the new york cavalry regiment
and they went out to go after booth in
virginia
and uh they also were accompanied by a
intelligence officer an intelligence
officer named lieutenant colonel everton
conger
um now they so they go down the potomac
uh by boat and then they land in
virginia at 10 p.m and then they go
across and they kind of like tracked
booth and harold who were still on the
run to
a farm owned by richard h garrett which
was about two miles south of port royal
virginia
so booth and harold had actually got to
this farm
on april 24th
and they had been brought there by
another guy named william jett who had
been a private in the ninth virginia
cavalry
now the garrett's i guess this farm was
kind of out in the middle of nowhere
because the garretts actually didn't
know that lincoln had been assassinated
i guess that the news hadn't reached
them yet yeah because it was the
internet it was before the internet yeah
um so they didn't know and so when they
bring booth there they're like hey this
is my friend
james boyd
um and he was a confederate soldier and
he was wounded in a battle and um you
know he's coming home can we just like
come in and get some food and blah blah
now apparently like later on i guess
this family at this farm they had an 11
year old son at the time named richard
and richard later gave an account of
like what ended up happening
so he said
that booth and harold got there at about
three in the afternoon
and because you know the confederacy had
kind of collapsed and they weren't
getting mail and [ __ ] like that like
they didn't know anything about the
assassination they didn't so obviously
they didn't know who this was
and they didn't you know he was famous
but they didn't know who he was either
so they're all having dinner together
and booth uh learned about uh the
surrender of johnson's army who was the
last confederate armed force of any size
which was kind of like that's
that's a wrap like the you know the fat
lady saying the civil war is over
and uh so he's like oh well my
assassination attempt failed like i said
it seemed kind of late in the game to be
surprised that an assassination attempt
would
like i said he you know lee had already
surrendered when he did that so it's
like i just feel like it was all over
but the shouting so i don't really know
why he was surprised by that but he's
just like oh well i guess i failed
and basically they're like um
the garrett's so i guess somebody else
at the dinner table like told the
garrett oh hey did you hear like lincoln
got shot and there's this big huge
reward
for the guy that uh shot him like a
hundred thousand dollars which like i
said was like two million dollars back
then like nowadays
um
so they said
that booth actually like said nothing
and asked if the family oh well
just hypothetically
would you guys turn in the guy
if you had him in your clutches
and um you know what i mean and the
family are just completely clueless well
maybe i mean if we need them we need we
do need the money so maybe i just
thought it was kind of funny and he was
probably like sitting there [ __ ] his
pants because he's like oh my god i did
it but yeah that's like i don't know
that story was just like very very funny
to me
so uh so at this point so conger who was
like with the 26 union guys that are
tracking booth at this point he finds
jet the guy that took him to the farm
and he interrogates him and then finds
out like where the garrett's farm is and
that's where booth is
so
before dawn april 26th uh all the
soldiers caught up with the fugitives at
this farm and at this point uh you know
booth and uh harold were hiding in the
tobacco barn
now you know the troops like surrounded
and were like hey come the [ __ ] out of
there uh harold surrendered
but booth
um
wouldn't do it he said i prefer to come
out and fight
yeah well okay
so then
as if in retaliation the soldiers just
were like [ __ ] that and they set the
barn on fire
to get the guy to come out
so booth is like still inside the barn
and uh apparently there was a sergeant
named boston corbett who like kind of
went in there and just shot him
basically shot him in the neck he didn't
he didn't kill him right away but yeah
shot him in the neck
um now he said that uh the [ __ ]
raised uh a pistol to shoot at me so i
shot him
although conger his superior
said that um
that actually corbett shot him just shot
him and that he should get in trouble
because we were supposed to bring him
back alive and he was kind of mad so i
don't really know like how it went
either way because there's you know
obviously two people said two different
things
so they dragged booth out
because they shot him in the neck and he
was paralyzed uh so they dried so they
dragged him outside and uh put him on
the porch
and then he lived for about another
three hours uh but he died after that
age 26 years old now um
[Music]
apparently his last words well not
exactly his last words but one of the
last things he said was tell my mother i
died for my country he wanted them to
say that
and they said also that right before he
died he held his hands up in front of
his face and said useless
useless
his hands were useless i don't know if
he was just delusional or if he really
meant that like my hands are useless
because
i didn't
because i shot the dude and it didn't do
any good or i guess i don't know no he's
just dying i don't know i don't know
what it was it probably just misses all
for nothing
that's kind of what i was thinking that
it's like i did it and it was all for
nothing yeah now after he died uh his
brother edwin who like i said had said
get the [ __ ] out of my house and never
come back because they really did not
agree about politics
um edwin wrote to
asia who i don't think agreed with his
political views but at least was still
talking to him
edwin wrote a letter to her and said
think no more of him as your brother
he's dead to us now as he soon must be
to all the world but imagine the boy you
loved to be in that better part of his
spirit in another world
asia the sister she also had um a letter
that booth had given her
and he said open this after i'm dead
and in the letter he said
i know how foolish i shall be deemed for
undertaking such a step as this where on
one side i have many friends and
everything to make me happy to give up
all seems insane i agree
but god is my judge i love justice more
than i do a country that disowns it more
than fame or wealth
so that's what he said in the letter so
i guess like i said he didn't regret it
he was a true believer
um so basically i mean like i said he
he even wrote they they seized like a
bunch of his letters that he had written
like to his family
um afterward
and
basically
he says i've ever held the south was
right that was another thing he said one
of his letters and looking upon african
slavery from the same standpoint held by
the noble framers of our constitution i
for one have ever considered it one of
the greatest blessings
both for themselves and us that god has
ever bestowed upon a favored nation
so he's saying slavery was good for
white people that black people that's
what he said that's what he said that's
what i said he was a big fan he was a
big fan
so uh so yeah so they wrapped him up in
a blanket and tied him to a farm wagon
and like drove him back to the [ __ ]
uh yeah so they drove him back and like
i said now this is kind of where
there was some controversy because some
people said oh like
uh
you know the nobody that was there like
that identified and really knew him and
it's like it really he lived and [ __ ]
like that which we'll i'll get into in a
second
but when they took his body they said
they took it to the uss montauk and then
they took it to the washington navy yard
uh for like iding and they were gonna do
an autopsy and [ __ ]
now when the body was there when they
were doing the ids
um
ten people
came that knew him and said yeah that's
him you know what i mean so it wasn't
like just random ass people like people
did come to knew him and they said that
they knew it was him because he had like
a tattoo on his left hand with his
initials on it i guess in case you
forgot what they were um and he had like
a scar on the back of his neck they said
was very distinctive and they recognized
that as well
so they buried uh him in a they put him
kind of like in a storage room at a
penitentiary and then they later moved
to a warehouse and then they were gonna
like um
before actually before they buried it
they actually had it identified
again like in the family plot
so they did like i said have family
members and friends and stuff like that
did actually like come and identify him
so it wasn't like just a bunch of
strangers or anything
now eight other people that were
implicated in the assassination
conspiracy uh were actually tried by a
military tribunal
and found guilty in june of 1865. uh
mary sarat lewis powell david harold and
george atzeroth were all hanged uh in
july of 1865. samuel mudd the doctor uh
samuel arnold and michael o'loughlin got
life imprisonment um there was in uh
florida
in fort jefferson
uh there was another guy named edmund
spangler he got six years in prison
o'loughlin died
in from yellow fever in 1867 like in
prison and the others were eventually
pardoned in 1869 by the incoming
president andrew johnson who had been
the vice president under abe lincoln
so uh let's see where was i okay
yeah after lincoln was gone
uh and peace started to come in they
kind of did everything they could to try
to
leave the war in the past they started
releasing a lot of people
and pardoning people
because they knew that they couldn't
really really [ __ ]
continue doing what they were doing
things had to go back to normal
i mean you couldn't [ __ ]
you couldn't wipe out and [ __ ]
imprison [ __ ] 30 of the population
you know come on
we don't have the space for that come on
yeah
they didn't have the power either well
yeah i'm just saying well yeah i'm
trying to be the best thing to do is
they would start to try to smooth it all
over
at least on the surface other [ __ ] that
they were doing
like sucking all the wealth out of the
[ __ ] south and sending wealthy
northern families into the south to take
over they did [ __ ] like that carpet
bagging you know carbon baggers so
they had a new campaign to try and to
make
make the south more northern didn't work
though didn't work
every one of those northern families you
[ __ ] set here
within a generation later they were just
[ __ ] as southern as you can [ __ ]
just southern as hell
sorry
so yeah so the whole thing about booth
like uh oh it wasn't really his body and
it was a look-alike and stuff like that
all of that comes from
1907.
there was a book called escape and
suicide of john wilkes booth
and that the whole
uh thing in that book was that actually
like somebody that just looked like
booth was killed at the farm and then
booth got away
so the whole story was that booth
actually took up the name john saint
helen
and uh had a house near glen rose texas
and then later moved to granbury texas
now when he got sick and was on his
deathbed
he made a deathbed confession one of
those famous deathbed confessions uh
that hey i'm john wilkes booth
um what ended up happening was that
uh i
you know
i don't know it was just kind of like
this whole story that he just [ __ ]
got away and ended up [ __ ] committing
suicide went away and committed suicide
like
his name was david george and all this
other kind of crap so there was all this
kind of like big conspiracy theory like
i said that was where i first got the
idea and i was like oh that might be
kind of interesting but the more i
looked into it i was just kind of like
oh okay probably not they asked me if
john will's booth's gun could penetrate
a modern bulletproof vest no it would
just splatter
lead was real soft it was heavy but it
was just
it was just splattered
low velocity
yeah i think somebody brought that up
like later on because that was a long
time oh somebody asked that yeah okay
that's that's okay
there was also um
the same guy that wrote the book that
said that uh john wilkes booth had
survived and then
you know got away and committed suicide
in 1983 or whatever
um
he also exhibited this guy's mummified
body
on the carnival circuit as the man who
shot abraham lincoln so i kind of feel
like there might have been
some monetary gain there maybe
um so because that this
rumor had started going around the
maryland historical society puts out
this account
in 1913
by the mayor of baltimore
um and he actually had seen booth's
remains like when they brought the
casket to the weaver funeral home
and uh the mayor had actually known
booth quite well when he was a little
bit younger
and he's basically like yeah the body i
saw was absolutely boots
and as i said like other people had
identified the body too like his mom uh
his sister his brother uh his dentist
and some other friends of his that he'd
known in baltimore so it like i said it
was absolutely him i just feel like the
guy that wrote that book in 1907
had a corpse laying around that he
wanted to put on the carnival circuit
and he's like hey i'm gonna latch it
onto that so he wrote a book to go along
with it it's like hey it's the man that
shot lincoln okay come and see him at
the carnival five cents you know what i
mean
but uh yeah so
that's kind of thing and honestly like i
kind of feel like that rumor keeps going
around like every few years because they
said that yeah like in the early like
1907 1913 somewhere around there like uh
you know beyond the carnival circuit
here's the man who shot lincoln like the
mommy or whatever but they said then
like it happened again like in 1920 and
like it started going like an urban
legend type of thing and so he was like
woohoo i'm gonna like start doing like
show in the body again and there was
that kind of stuff too so i kind of feel
like maybe that's all that was just like
a carny trick maybe i don't know but uh
yeah i but i did look into it and it
really didn't seem like there was much
to it because a lot of people did
actually identify him that actually knew
him including his family members so
there was that and also he had a pretty
distinctive tattoo and a scar and
everything like that so
so i don't think he survived because
like i said who the [ __ ] else was it was
just him and that one other guy you know
what i mean yeah and
they knew that's where he was
they just looked through the bar and
it's like oh he's in the barn and they
[ __ ] shot him yeah they dragged him
out they dragged his ass out
i just kind of feel like that it
happened the way all the people said it
happened well some people wanted it to
be more complicated than that well i
kind of feel like that's the problem but
it's like sometimes [ __ ] just happened
the way people said it happened it's not
mysterious it's not
scary it's not anything like that it's
like it's probably just role
james one of these days because he had a
bunch of con bunch of uh uh confederate
connections you know um
yeah we haven't done one about jesse
james have we didn't we did that's a
true crime you could do right there and
um many have said that
jesse james and his
gang
were robbing those trains and
doing all that stuff as a
basically a uh
ex-confederate special operation to get
the money together to fight a fighter
resistance campaign to get the north out
of the out of the south again there may
be something to it
he had the military background
and evidently the connections
and there is a bunch of missing money
or you know
missing stolen stuff what happened to
was he stopped was he stashing it and
stockpiling it somewhere
knows that's those are some of the
conspiracy theories around it maybe if
not he was just raiding
raiding [ __ ] trains because he he's
like these are enemy trains i'm gonna
take this [ __ ] you know it might have
been that
dude who's just not gonna
he's eventually just shot in the back by
while he was hanging a pitcher
on a wall
but um
evidently he thought he was out of the
game
at that point
so maybe for a while i don't know it's
hard to tell be interesting to look into
it
yeah i kind of feel like uh yeah ben
frail said jesse james ned kelly same
folk belief in survival now we did do a
show about ned kelly uh not too long ago
i could have sworn we did one about
jesse james but i guess we didn't i
don't think so no we've done a couple
old west shows though yeah i feel like
yeah i just can't remember what they
were i know we did like a ghost of the
old west show that was fun but
he was an accomplished train robber
jesse was good at that i just can't
remember like what the other ones were i
know we've done a couple of old west
shows but i can't remember what they
were at the moment
so there's that but yeah so
people gave me some ideas so i'll put
those in the next uh poll which if
you're a patreon a patron which you
should be
then uh i usually put the polls up
friday mornings or at least friday
mornings eastern standard time and
there's five different topics you can
pick from i try to have a good complex
good combo in there of like a paranormal
topic true crime topic historical topic
you know [ __ ] like that so people can
like pick and you can also like choose
what movie we do a movie retrospective
on i also give five choices for that as
well and you also get to find out like
what shows are coming up then next week
yeah abandoned here is coming up with
some good [ __ ] yeah you also forgot
about elvis folk belief in survival i
could go on about elvis in the south
when i grew up as a kid
you s above people's mantles were
[ __ ] pictures of jesus and elvis
right next to each other and when you
looked at them [ __ ] they looked all
the pictures of jesus did look like
elvis and [ __ ] elvis was a miss
messianic figure in mississippi
definitely
stories about that he could make it rain
crazy [ __ ] man
and then when orion appeared
people thought that it was it was elvis
[ __ ] returned from the grave
and that was a dude from mississippi who
could sound just like elvis he put the
mask on and it did look like elvis when
he had that [ __ ] mask on
listen to orion's music well they talked
about that some i think like we got kind
of into it because we watched a
documentary about orion yeah and
it kind of goes a little bit into the
whole mythologizing about illness and
about how like you said he was like a
messianic i'm old enough to know when
all that [ __ ] was happened when i was a
kid
of how
southerners from the 70s and the 80s the
very early 80s how how they saw elvis
like my parents generation
and then like the orion thing you know
what i mean i can i can [ __ ] yeah
i didn't hear about orion until later
but i could see how i saw the films of
of southerners reacting to orion and i
was looking at the album covers that had
the funeral
a funerary motif like he had come back
and it's hinting that it's elvis back
from the [ __ ] grave
yeah
southerners wanted to believe that
certain southerners in mississippi
wanted to believe that
that's why he should have never taken
that mask off
yeah that was a mistake yeah
the soup
not just religion but anything [ __ ]
supernatural
and and the belief in the supernatural
the paranormal
is very strong in the south
people don't understand it's very strong
um
as strong as say mexico
especially that generation
you know it's a shame that it subsided
some because that was part of the
of the mythos part of the soul of the
south was to believe in these things
um
and there's truth to these things
because [ __ ] i've had out-of-body
experiences near-death experiences seen
poultry guys phenomenon
think i
was in a house that was bad i think
you'd call it a haunted house but never
really could prove it
um
but the south is just a wash in that
including um
blues
you know and and uh southern black
population very much into the
paranormal you know it goes all the way
back to
with the haitian influences and stuff
you know and down in new orleans and
everything and
selling your soul to the devil to
crossroads and all that kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] no we did talk about that yeah
that's robert johnson yeah yeah we
talked about that on our mysteries of
rock and roll
which was we did that a long time ago
but that was fun we should probably do
like a part two of that right so it's
just
very strong in the south
um actually maybe i should write that
down i mean eventually even iron maiden
is [ __ ] singing songs about [ __ ]
the
mississippi delta swamp [ __ ] demons
and [ __ ] the [ __ ] evil spirits in the
south so you know it took a while for
even iron maiden to get around it back
when they started to suck because
because metallica kicked the little [ __ ]
out of them
but you know
but yeah they got it too
and uh
that's why i interviewed the vampire
[ __ ] was so good you know
because that's kind of true to the south
to the southern mentality
i kind of feel like any thing because
like what ben frel was saying about
jesse james and ned kelly and stuff like
that i kind of feel like any
figure that is bigger than life
in any way
whether they're a celebrity or whether
you know they're a outlaw or whatever
it's almost kind of like they can't die
i mean i don't even know if people want
to say necessarily they can't die but
they can't just die in like a mundane
way yeah like you know i fell down the
stairs in my condo and and broke their
neck or something like monday it has to
be like some big
epic thing so like if they just die in
some stupid ass way
then everybody has to say well that
obviously can't be right you know what i
mean so i kind of feel like maybe
that's one of the things that might have
fueled the whole elvis didn't die type
thing
was because people didn't like
the way that he died because it was it
didn't befit his
legend
i mean he just died in a very like sad
mundane kind of way like a lot of people
die and i think that people had a hard
time dealing with that because like i
said he was so famous and he was so
larger than life and nobody wanted to
feel like somebody like that
could just like you know die on the can
like you know of [ __ ]
just having all these drug problems and
stuff like that nobody wanted to hear
that everybody wanted it to be like
mythical ben says he's got that orion
book he's never read it though
he must be are you southern ben how are
you doing with a [ __ ] book about ryan
that was a fascinating guy i mean it's a
sad story it's a sad story but i mean
there's a documentary about him i think
it's just called orion right and it
called orion something i think it had
like a subtitle dude sounded just like
elvis man just as good
and then retired in documentary he was
running a pawn shop and then somebody by
just random came in and [ __ ] shot him
and robbed his pawn shop yeah in the
middle of mississippi
that's what i mean it's just it's a sad
sad story yeah and the thing that's sad
about it too is that
i mean he got famous kinda
but
i mean he's in australia
really yeah
and he's talking in italy scotland
ireland rural france famous hiring with
highwaymen and robbers or whatever he
starts to be immortal yeah that's what
i'm saying because they get to a point
where they're like bigger than life and
they can't just be taken out in some
mundane ass way because that's not how
it works he's he's australian he knows
his [ __ ] he even knows who o'riah was
well i kind of i told you this before i
don't know about nowadays but i know
that particularly in the late 70s and
early 80s there was a lot of because i'm
was really into like nick cave and stuff
like that and i know that so a lot of
like australians yeah they were all into
like mythologizing the south and blues
and everything like that like if you re
like if you hear his early stuff or like
his stuff with the birthday party and
stuff like that very very blues
influence if you don't live here you
hear all this [ __ ] horror stories
about the south and everything [ __ ]
the civil war [ __ ] slavery and [ __ ]
the thing is though is that if you were
to actually go through just a survey
just over the years the the south has a
has the highest life satisfaction
[ __ ] rates of anywhere in the united
states
mississippi has
the lowest incomes
um it's 33
i think it's 30 31 or 33 black which is
that it's the highest black population
the lowest crime rate
the lowest
um
uh what is it the lowest crime rate
lowest incomes
lowest education
the highest amount of guns
but the highest satisfaction the life
satisfaction scores of all all
of all the other states
and and the south is kind of like that
and the other states are kind of
comparable the other southern states are
kind of comparable
and what it is is that the south is fun
the south has a fun culture
it's not
very materialistic
uh
it's it it's just
it's it's fun to live in the south and
um
they don't micromanage you that much
money goes a long way
you don't make much of it but it it goes
a long way when things are running
normally
uh it you can party [ __ ] you can
party a lot here
uh
you'll find people who are like you no
matter where you are in the south
like i live in that middle of nowhere
i'd go to new orleans [ __ ] almost
every weekend [ __ ] have all kinds of
fun
uh hanging out in goth clubs and stuff
oh go down and pass christian
mississippi or biloxi
[ __ ] you know thought the casinos you
know like something out of star wars man
the south is like something out of star
wars
it's just a lot of fun you know
you can live out the middle of nowhere
if you want to or you can live in a town
or you can live in a city or you can
live in a [ __ ] place
filled with [ __ ] casinos or or you
can go into the south or you can go into
[ __ ] south florida and that's like
being in the bahamas or something you
know it's just
it's a fun place
got a lot to choose from
yeah kind of and as they don't climb up
your ass it's nothing like boston
boston micro managing [ __ ] man
make you pay for any everything
it's just
a lot more fun in california california
is all about traffic and
no
high population density
michigan was
kind of fun but michigan's very bland
all right
looking um
it's good for certain things but it's
not good for other things
most states are kind of like that
including the southern states it's good
for some things but not good for other
things
but i i'm still glad to be back in the
south you know south is fun
yeah let's see yeah
um all right so i guess nobody else is
talking about anything
anything else you would like to talk
about that's about you want to run it
you want to shut it down i mean i'm done
with my notes look so if you want to
like get and talk about something else
you can no that's it are we going to
have to um
are you hungry yeah a little bit
i got i can make another pizza if you
want to i got more dough or i can uh
make burgers uh but if not we can we got
uh more hauntings to watch
yeah we had it we didn't realize this we
bought season eight on amazon prime yeah
and then we were like we went to watch
another one last night and i was like oh
we watched them already because it was
only six episodes six episodes yeah
so then we go to buy season nine and
it's like it looks like it's there but
they don't have it like available so you
can't you can't buy it or rent it or
rent it so i don't know why it must be
some rights issue so they don't have
nine or ten but we bought 11 which i
don't know how many episodes it is but
it was only 4.99 for the whole season
yeah and the first season the first
episode was about a case here in florida
and it was a little uh it was [ __ ]
wild
okay those from india came and got her
yeah we should probably do a show about
it once i want to do a show about it
because yeah it was in stuart florida
yeah and okay it demonstrates one of the
things i know what you know it's we're
we're done talking about john wilkes
booth now but i we wanted to get back
into like the haunting
or a haunting because
i realized one of the things that's
different
from the old ones to the new ones one of
the things that really stands out to me
i'm sure there's more than one thing
but one of the things that stands out
the most to me is that i feel like the
later seasons
um
they didn't shoot as much footage
because they reuse footage like a lot
what they'll do is like they'll have
this [ __ ] happen you know blah blah
there's a shadow going behind the person
or whatever then they go to commercial
break but obviously we bought it so you
know we don't have a commercial break
and then it comes back and then they
show you like two or three minutes of
the same [ __ ] over again yeah like it's
i'm like we just
saw this and it's like i feel like they
don't do that as much on the old ones so
i kind of feel like the old ones maybe
they took it more seriously or maybe
they had more money and they shot more
footage this like the newer ones it
seems like they shot a lot less footage
because they keep reusing it stretch it
out to stretch it out and like it's yeah
it seems like the stories are a lot less
substantive
and so they keep repeating the same
things over and over well we'll see we
only saw the first episode of this
season well you know what i mean
i'll be i can judge it better when i see
a few more of the seasons but it's a few
more of the episodes out of the season
that last season was kind of like that
though wouldn't it
yeah i mean and actually um that was
like years before this one so we'll see
how many yeah and like i said the season
eight like had some of that but it
wasn't too bad but then like when we got
season 11
and we just saw the first episode and it
seemed like they did it a lot in that
one because it really didn't seem like
they had much substance to that story so
they kept like
showing the same thing over and over
that last season though i would say the
quality isn't isn't substantially worse
than the other ones it's just a little
bit less yeah just a little bit
and i don't think the music is quite as
good yeah
so far in this one the music didn't seem
as good in in the first episode of this
season the music seems to be canned
music
i don't think it was and i don't know if
it was just because this particular
episode was based around a ghost that
supposedly like followed them home from
india
on the plane
i was like i was imagining all kinds of
scenarios
like i was like where did the ghost hide
in the plane like when she was flying
back because the lady was um
she worked on a she worked at an airline
worked for airline and she flew back and
forth to uh
to new delhi all the time
and apparently she had brought a an
indian ghost lady with her so there was
that
american military 100 said jenny will
you ever do a show about sophie
lancaster the girl murdered for being
goth yeah i actually uh was in england
yeah i actually had one terrible yeah
yeah that was like that's stupid [ __ ]
they beat up that [ __ ]
girl she was cute man real cute and some
dude some goth dude he was just normal
looking guy hey [ __ ] how
i don't understand that [ __ ]
i don't know the exact [ __ ]
play-by-play i i didn't listen to the
witness testimony
but no that [ __ ]
were they beat to death because of how
they looked or did a fight ensue over
how they looked and beat her to death
for what she said i don't know
you know what i mean not not to say that
it makes it any better it just makes a
little bit more understandable how can
you just see some hot guy check and go i
don't like that and just beat her to
death oh it happens i'm sure
it happens it makes sense well the weird
thing about it is i don't know i don't i
don't really understand like look even
if i'm walking down the street and i see
somebody that i think looks weird or
[ __ ] up i'm i i never it never occurs
to me like hey i'm gonna go beat up that
yeah or hey i'm gonna go like [ __ ] with
that bird like leave him alone who
[ __ ] kid doesn't have anything to do
with you where's so i'm gonna do a scoff
at that person like oh look at that [ __ ]
you know that's the worst i'm gonna do
well that's what i mean it's like and
why would you even do that like i said
it's like you don't know them they don't
know you it's like nothing to do with
you so it's just like why the [ __ ] do
you think there's so many clothes yeah
i've seen so many freakazoids i don't
even laugh at the way people are dressed
i will laugh at the way they're not
dressed they might forget no style
yeah i'm more willing to i'm i'm more
inclined to like laugh at you if you
just like you know come in the club with
like your cargo shorts and your crocs on
or dude then i'll laugh dude you're
wearing plaid pants and a [ __ ]
striped shirt dude
you know
i can understand laughing at that but
i'm not going to like punch a dude out
or anything like that no and i'm not
going to be like super obvious about it
either i might like laugh at him behind
my hand
but it's just like i said it's none of
my business wear what you want i'll give
crap
people probably laugh at [ __ ] i wear all
the time i don't care
you know
[ __ ] man it's like we see people come in
there like dressed like furries and [ __ ]
like that everybody's like whatevs
whatever i don't care yeah the clubs we
go to are you
other people taz is normal
okay
other people would just see it as a
circus
and in some ways i see it as
entertainment too everybody's there to
entertain one another but it's just all
i just take it all for granted that some
[ __ ] gonna show up as a furry
that somebody else is gonna be just
gender bending the [ __ ] out of this and
then you're gonna have some [ __ ]
gender non-binary this and then you got
a [ __ ] gothic [ __ ] mega queen with
her [ __ ] titties and all kinds of
[ __ ] then you're gonna have [ __ ]
fetish boy and then you're gonna and
these are all just
archetypes that we well the thing is
like and then they just walk in
everybody just kind of like hey what's
up man yeah
[Laughter]
you know you're not impressing anybody
well
you can't impress somebody but um it's
not you're not gonna shock anybody and
nobody
you know you're not really making it
even you're not really even making a
statement
their people are kind of indifferent
now
you come in decked out in a fantastic
outfit you just [ __ ] gorgeous with
the [ __ ] booty like
kerosene kitty or something and all she
does is post pictures of her booty and
just dances with her booty everybody
[ __ ] knows you know what i mean
what that's about
so you'll get
you'll get attention that way but that's
not your clothes it's what's in that
clothes there's a lot of those
you know you got some people that are
just
gifted
you know what i mean
and
that'll get you attention
in the clubs but nothing else really
will
like i said it would take a lot like i
don't really know sometimes because i
kind of feel like we brought this up
before especially like in when you go to
goth clubs and you have like some kind
of like normal people that come in there
yeah and sometimes they'll try to like
get attention by coming in and being
like
like acting i'm like mostly everyone
will just be annoyed at you yeah they're
like oh [ __ ] they just be like uh here
we go yeah how long before these
[ __ ] get kicked out
it's like
five four what ends up impressive
what ends up impressing people in
in the clubs that we go to ends up being
basically a mixture of good taste
and genetics
that's that's which is that's i think
that's universal with all scenes
yeah i mean if somebody comes in looking
really good looking like they got their
[ __ ] all tight and like and they're
locked down and whatnot and they're
wearing something that suits them and
it's got a [ __ ]
it's got mojo behind it it doesn't have
to it could be anything it could be just
like a punk rock outfit that [ __ ] his
fan or a goth outfit or a [ __ ] it
could be a 70s outfit
okay
something that looks distinctive you
know it you know and you're working it
wow you know we've had
[ __ ] there's you know uh sean has
come in in
70s retro outfits
with [ __ ] bell bottoms and everything
and looked great you know
but you can't just [ __ ] where's you
know i don't know
i don't want to talk about it that's not
how you can't just wear some [ __ ]
and get
and get [ __ ] attention
you
yeah it's a picture it it's yes there's
a lot of other things a bunch of other
factors it does
and half of that [ __ ]
genetics
how you look
you know
that's that's that's you know and that's
that is
a constant throughout all scenes
dj maniac said this it doesn't seem to
work for me anymore i dress to the nines
i'm hot as [ __ ] but i think these girls
get a daddy vibe from me these days go
on hrt i mean well well the thing you
have to admit that like once you get
past a certain age once you get past the
search people aren't gonna no matter how
good you look people aren't gonna look
at you the same as they're gonna look at
some like [ __ ] 25 year old the
average the average woman becomes
invisible at 40. the average man becomes
invisible at 50.
all right so you can't be the average
man or woman that's the secret
you can't be average
and you're gonna have to [ __ ]
look towards
fitness and technology and sports
medicine but even that can only do so
much because i mean i mean
you're still going to look older than
and obviously if somebody that's a lot
younger comes in everybody's going to
pay attention the thing is though is
this will tell you they'll tell any
[ __ ] really good cosmetic surgeon
will tell you this or a plastic surgeon
the secret to [ __ ] being attractive
when you're older is not to look younger
it's just to be more attractive so a lot
of the stuff that they do to people and
things that you can do to yourself
is to make you look more attractive not
to make you look younger it's a [ __ ]
big you're never going to make an older
person look younger
do you understand what i'm getting it's
just gonna look weird if it's gonna look
weird you can't make a younger you can't
make an older person look younger you
can only make an older person look
better
and that's that's how you do it
so
fitness has a lot to do with it getting
weight off has a lot to do with it
you there are women out there in their
[ __ ]
70s that look great
i saw him at the damn biker bar
with boyfriends who were in their 30s
remember i told you about that yeah
pocket chick
uh
she was thin
she had big implants
she has a little bit of facial
work done here there there's probably a
little bit of hormonal assistance there
she didn't look young she looked hot
though to the top
and
dude was all about it her little 30
something year old boyfriend he just you
know and she looked great on the back of
a [ __ ] motorcycle the way she was
dressed looked [ __ ] great little
tight jeans and a [ __ ] little vest in
her boobs and her [ __ ] and she was
fun
fun
her little
white hair and little braids and stuff
and
she wasn't trying to look young she was
just
in good shape and took care of herself
and spent money on herself and she was a
model
that's what she was she was a model
but she had been a model when she was
young so
her self-esteem was looking good and she
just invested money in herself that's
how she
made money and felt good about herself
and she was i think she thinks she was
71 i think but
from what i saw she could do porn
and they do have porn stars that age
there's a few of them
and you know
some of them look good
and when i didn't show you that once you
look like a damn her whole thing she's
like a fetish looked like a damn wicked
witch with big old teddy's big little
skinny chick i'll show her to you
yeah i showed her on the show yeah
there's some out there she looked better
than that two or three times better than
that
so she could go to the club and score
guys
so you know so here's the deal you just
we're all going to die
we're all going to die the secret is is
to die strong and to look as good as you
can if you ask me that's that's that's
what i want to do and my role model is
not arnold schwarzenegger it's that
chinese guy that i've shown on there
he's 73 years old and he looks about
like i do at 73. he's a little bit dead
better looking than me in terms of
fitness and hardness you know a little
bit more mass and his
and i'm you know
i'm on some minotaur sauce right now
i'll pick up about 10 pounds over the
next month if maybe five to ten
and um if i can hold everything together
and um and i'm gonna make then once i
get that that's it i'm not gonna get any
bigger i'm just gonna maintain that and
[ __ ]
enhance things that i have and
just try to ride out the next 25 years
20 years you know
because we're all going to die
eventually or something i just want to
die in good health and die strong you
don't talk about
a half and be having fun the whole time
ben says just remember that 50 of people
are below average
[Laughter]
that kind of that makes you feel a
little better actually
jenny's way above average
[Laughter]
no jenny you're way above average
well no i mean i didn't really mean it
like that i was just saying no
zack says i need to get my ass to a goth
club before i decease jack yeah
that's it's not it's it's zach with a k
not zach with a i don't think how does
that i don't think gay zach has been
here this evening no okay yeah i hate to
call him gay zach and straight yeah we
got straight straight zagg
[Laughter]
well you got to find your local one
and uh i mean some people are better
than others but yeah some are better
than go there go mind your own business
and just [ __ ] keep your eye out and
just watch what's happening
get to know people start at the bottom
and work your way up don't try to make
friends just try to make peace just go
in there and just see what the hell is
going on first you know which reminds me
we got momentum more on friday night
okay so we gotta go after the side
tracks right
so we'll be going out after the side
tracks there were two this month because
it was a holiday yeah and whenever
there's a sunday night holiday they
always have one on or whenever there's a
monday holiday they always have a sunday
night like supplemental
but they usually do it on friday nights
which is what they're doing on this
friday
so
you know so we'll be going out on friday
night
uh
i think that's all that i wanted to
address okay so we were on almost three
hours so that's
something and i got through my
notes and i got like a bunch of good
ideas for new
show topics all right so i'll put those
in the poll for
friday morning so yeah thanks everybody
for dropping by and hanging out with us
thanks for your super chats uh we're
gonna take the day off tomorrow but we
will be back on friday night for the
side track show have a drink and talk
with you guys and then like i said
probably going out afterward so hope you
guys enjoyed this little historical
show that we did this evening yeah and
we will see you guys again friday night
what oh yeah yeah
dj maniac he named because sally
d'angelo that's right sal diana that's
who it was yeah she's the oldest one i
know of that's in there i remember you
know i don't really remember what she
looks like she's amusing she's she's
left yeah all right so we'll see you
guys on friday night good night yeah